keto you have a quote on your Facebook I
think it was from an interview that you
did and the quote begins with make sure
you want it yes
I'm wondering can I continue I'll let
you know more of what you said here if
you want me to remind you so it's um
trust your own talent and the
singularity of your own voice be careful
who you listen to and if this is what
you want don't get easily discouraged
what does that mean make sure you want
it that's fascinating
um yeah so I know a lot of talented
people talented writers talented artists
in general but Talent is only a part of
the equation I feel like in in this
medium you know it's so competitive and
so tough and it's so hard to get people
to care
um your talent can only get you so far
it's important
um you know by the way you don't have to
be talented I feel like persistence and
I'm not saying anything new here but
persistence is so much more important or
as important as Talent so creativity I
feel like you can develop it right you
don't have to be born creative you can
nurture it
but there's a part of you that has has
to hustle so one you can't fake it if
you don't want it
and this applies to actors directors
writers people can tell if you desire it
and if you don't that's totally fine and
I'm not going to tell people what line
of work they should be in but
you can sense when someone really wants
to tell a story when someone wants to
because writing is not necessarily easy
it's whoever tells you writing is easy
I you know I suspect that statement
um I'm not saying it's the hardest thing
they're hardest jobs for sure but
there's something about writing that's
exhausting because it's you know it
involves an emotional introspection
um trying to figure out who you are what
do you want to talk about what resonates
with you what resonates with other
people so it is draining
um that's why you know I I can only
write a certain amount of pages a day
because I want to write something that's
truthful and writing truthful Pages
takes a lot of energy a lot of thought a
lot of asking questions a lot of doubt
that's why you know I didn't mean that
quote to be daunting what I mean is
um if you really want to do this then no
one can stop you just you know there can
be failure along the way that there can
be many frustrations I mean daily every
writer will know this you know
some days you just write great Pages
some days it doesn't work some days you
write bad or bad Pages or you get
rejections or you get awful notes you
know notes that you don't know what to
do with like how am I going to apply
this note and it's a job you can't say
no right
um so what I meant is
you know if the desire is there if the
flame is within you then you got the
most important thing
how should someone
quote unquote check themselves to know
if they really want it because I think
we all think we want certain things and
then once we go through the process day
in and day out then it becomes clear to
us what it actually is yeah I it's a
good question
um so I don't I don't intend to be a
guru of any sorts and sometimes the line
is a bit blurry between like self-help
and you know but
um it is a very intimate thing you know
to me at least writing is a very
intimate thing very personal thing
even if I'm not writing about my own
life which I rarely do it is incredibly
person I care about it and you know
there are moments of Doubt of course
there were moments and there are still
moments when I wonder is this the best
way to channel my abilities my skills my
talent
the truth is over the years I keep doing
it and the fact that I keep going back
to it means that I actually care that to
me is the the best evidence that I I am
a writer this is not a hobby this is not
something that I'm good at I mean I'm
good at certain things that I don't
necessarily spend time on I don't know I
guess I could have been a good lawyer
I've thought about this many times I
would have certainly made more money I
would have been more stable my dad would
have been delighted
but that's not how it went you know
there's a Creative Energy there's a need
to express yourself through stories
because I mean I've I've been a film
critic for 10 years before actually
become a screenwriter
and you know that's that's a long story
how I became a film critic I don't think
any child you know any eight
ten-year-old child says I want to become
a film critic right
um but it happened and I'm I'm glad it
did
um but you know being a journalist or
um writing in that film analysis which I
did that's not that's a whole different
approach it's still writing
but it's not a I mean it is creative but
it's it's it's not the same way to apply
your your emotion your brain
it's very different
so at some point I had to question
myself you know do I want to analyze a
film that's already made and out there
someone else's work or do I want to
produce my own work
and that takes courage and that takes
facing your fears and limitations and
you know it's it's it's really hard to
write a script
if you were an attorney presenting your
own case
so you were you were employed by Guido
Segal and you were speaking to the jury
about why Guido should continue
on this path so ladies and gentlemen of
the jury I present to you my client and
and he really wants this he's not sure
if it'll ever pan out or I don't know
what would what would the argument be
how would you convince 12 jurors with
their arms crossed that
I guess what I would say is I like a
good challenge and this is the most
challenging and exciting thing that I've
found
um I don't I don't know if I could have
been a doctor in the sense that I
couldn't do the same thing over and over
and over again and with writing it's
always new no script is or play I guess
or novel they're never the same so with
practice you get better at it but every
new story you face or you know you have
to break down
uh post this new a new set of new
challenges and that to me is very
exciting
so persistence we're going back to what
you said originally that Talent
necessarily it's not always in the
equation it's persistence yeah I mean
and especially in in a city like La
there's so many talented people and I
don't say this you know lightly I mean
I've met so many talented writers that
come from all over the country all over
the world
um and they're here for a reason but to
make it here I mean I'm again I don't
want to be the one saying what it means
to make it I would say to get a job or
to have several jobs that just just to
be paid to write means a lot
I want to be very realistic of course
you need a dream we all have one or many
dreams but
I think my goal is to keep to be paid to
write and that to me is the dream it's
so maybe I've become older and jaded and
more realistic but it's so hard to get
paid to the right to write to get paid
to be an artist a creative
um
so you have to constantly negotiate with
what the industry wants and the
standards and what you want and
it's not necessarily the same of course
when you get to I guess to a certain
point in your career that you're in
control you can decide
but still I mean I I remember I I met
Paul feig right
um who did I wrote and directed
bridesmaids among Ghostbusters among
many other things and I asked him uh
Paul when is the right time to do your
passion project and he said never never
is the right time and you just do it if
you want but know that it's risky
when you were in grade school or as a
teenager were you bored in school
no I actually you know I gotta I was I
was a nerd um I was very I wasn't a
troublemaker
um I actually loved
um loved school I know that's not a
common thing to say but I loved learning
I loved history
I did okay with math and physics and
chemistry you know all those subjects
but
um literature
history later on philosophy like I
connected to all that you know and I
love I've always loved reading
I guess when I decided to be a filmmaker
um
you know and I still dream about
directing I don't know I don't think I'm
a director by Nature
um because I love words I work with
words and that's why
since I love films and I love literature
I'm a writer I mean and it makes so much
sense for me to be a screenwriter
um
but no I mean I actually love school
and grad school and and you know college
was the passion project ever the right
time did you find time to make yours
or it's still in the works well it's you
know I I had a TV I have a TV show that
I've developed that I've written the
pilot and it's been in development for
three years
and it's period I mean and again I don't
make it easy on myself you know it's
it's an expensive show it's period it's
about the 60s uh in Chicago sorry to
interrupt I well by the way this is the
thing I I didn't set out to be a period
writer but um I guess it's it resonates
with me so I I wrote one show that takes
place in the late 60s in Chicago
um
that I don't think that's gonna happen
by the way because they
um
the way I make the movie I I think it's
about the young Lords and of course you
know I'm me not being Puerto Rican
um doesn't help I got very I met
um some of those historical figures I
interviewed them
um it was really interesting but
um Sometimes some things don't pan out
and you just let them go and that's you
know uh this show no the show is is uh
takes place mostly in Boston in the 60s
it's about psychedelics
um and um you just gotta be patient you
know I've written that script so many
times and Rewritten it and um
you know it takes time and money and
getting people attached this is about
Timothy Leary yes it is okay I as
growing up in San Francisco knew his
name a lot and um around interest yeah
so that's
um I I adapted this uh author who now
became my friend uh Robert Greenfield
and Bob wrote about all these figures in
the 60s like you know the Grateful Dead
Jerry Garcia and the Grateful Dead
Timothy Leary so I adapted Bob and we
became friends and he's like a mentor to
me now
um
so that opened up that script opened up
other doors to writing about you know
the 60s and rock and roll and
psychedelics and um and I clearly
connect even though I wasn't born around
that time I connect to that I felt the
same way even though I'm a gen xer so
yeah but there was something about being
there and just seeing just The Counter
Culture movement that was very
attractive and and yeah you know I I
what I suspect or what I feel at least
is that
um we have an idea of those of those
times and a feeling that there was a
dream of how Society could have been
um and then it didn't work out but for
you know for a few years it felt like
America at least could become place
where you know there was a certain
amount of freedom and and people were
against the Vietnam War and you know
expansion of consciousness and
um and I feel like a lot of what's
happening today is still you know is is
the the the effect of those of those
days like we're still we're going back
to some of the ideas and uh theories
um back in the day
um I I you know I'm seduced by the idea
of of a different Society where
everyone's welcome and you know you have
a certain amount of freedom to do what
you do as long as you don't hurt other
people
I guess that's why I go back to the 60s
or my idea of the 60s and is that one of
the reasons you say you don't make it
easy on yourself and that doing you know
doing the time diff you know in terms of
costumes and cars and and getting the
rights to music and things like that
would be a lot certainly I mean
period by itself you can see producers
get scared
um because we're talking if it's a TV
show we're talking about at least a two
million dollar episode in a 10 episode
season at least I'm saying right
um so it's costumes it's cars if it's
based on real people it's having the IP
which which I do but um
you know it's more challenging
um
so I I get this note or this comment
constantly which is why don't you write
something contemporary based on your own
story
and I usually reply to this
you know there is a lot of me in what
you read the fact that it's not
autobiographical doesn't mean it's not
incredibly personal
I mean I have I have been trying this is
the thing I mean this it's everyone has
their own approach I don't like to write
about myself explicitly
I don't feel like it's necessary
um but everyone's free to do whatever
they feel I mean
sure I mean I I incorporate parts of my
life and anecdotes into my writing but I
give it to someone else
you know that's my Approach
without asking anyone for feedback how
do you know you have a good story
wow that's an interesting question I
think every every writer or every
creative we have an intuition and over
time you you learn how to listen to that
intuition and and you know you know the
scene is working or not
um if the script is working or not
um
usually when you when you finish a draft
my immediate reaction usually is I'm
very proud of myself even though I won't
say it out loud
but I you know I'm satisfied and after a
couple of days I start seeing the gaps
or I start seeing the flaws you know
it's like my first reaction is
um okay at least I managed to put this
on paper
um then you go back to it and always I'm
always a bit scared to go back to it
because
when you're when you're actually on a
roll
um it's like a trance and sometimes you
don't you're not necessarily conscious
of what's going in there I mean you're
following your own
um the you know the scribble of the
scene and then you try to make it work
and come to life a life
um so when you go back to you have a
feeling which scenes are working which
scenes are not which scenes need to be
totally Rewritten
um
of course then you can ask for feedback
and and what I'd say about feedback is
um I always try to be extremely careful
about who I ask feedback for
so um it has to be a limited number of
people
as sweet people I really
um
that people who know what I'm trying to
achieve and who are not trying to change
what I'm what my my goal is but who or
trying to help me make it work
because it's extremely sensitive even
you know you're not entirely sure
at least I don't know any writer who's
100 sure unless if you're working for a
TV show and and you have this very
detailed outline well then you're just
following instructions right
but if it's your own script something
you didn't expect
um
you're never entirely sure so pick three
or four people you really trust who who
love you know your your baby because
that's what it is as you as you do who
will read carefully you know and who are
considerate and who'll give you honest
um feedback that's not bringing you down
I've made that mistake in the past where
I was trying to impress someone and I
gave them my first or second or third
draft
and the notes that God destroyed me you
know
and it's really hard to recover from
that because you're still not sure what
you're I mean people might say like you
know I wrote a great script
again I'm suspicious you know it's it's
it's a script is something very flexible
you you might have a very clear plan but
things change along the way you have to
let them change it has to evolve you
want it to be organic
um so I always you know I have my people
and they're always the same people
and and those who haven't given me good
notes or careful notes in the past I
don't send them any scripts anymore
unless of course you know it's producers
you're working for a director you're
working for or even your reps I mean
let's let's be honest you're I mean I'd
love to have
um reps who totally understand what I'm
doing it's not always the case you know
maybe you're a manager or your agent
don't
they you know they believe in your
potential maybe they don't connect to
your writing
and then well you know it's a matter of
when do you choose to to present your
material or if you have the the correct
representation
new screenwriter sitting across from you
and they said you know I gave my script
to several people and one person I
really respect their opinion but they
destroyed me with their notes and you
wouldn't think that because we have a
great relationship what would be your
advice to them why do you think somebody
would purposely try to do that
I think everyone has good and bad days
and we we never know what the other
person's going through
um and I say this after years of dealing
with terrible notes that make me feel
awful okay so it's not like I've become
enlightened but I had to deal with this
so
um with you know when you send out
things to contests or people read your
submission or even people you know and
respect
maybe they're having the worst day of
their lives and they will hate they will
hate your script no matter how good it
is
also
um people don't people don't like
reading scripts that's I mean I've
that's my conclusion you really gotta
insist and people will love your script
reluctantly that means for some reason
no one has ever has time to read scripts
they'll do it two weeks later a month
later
but when you've actually written a
really good script that you worked on
people have no choice but to admit how
good it is and actually you know I've I
remember doing internship internships
back in the day and reading scripts and
you don't want to like those scripts
because you're a writer and they're
writers and you don't want other writers
to succeed by the way you should learn
to be okay with other people's success
it takes time but you know no one's
success impacts yours I mean there's no
connection okay you're not a failure
because they're succeeding
and you know the sooner you acknowledge
this the better life you'll have which
is everyone's doing their own thing no
one's taking anything away from you
so um
you know I remember the feeling of being
an intern or working for doing coverage
and and you read scripts and whenever
you find one that actually clicks it's
an amazing thing like oh my God this
script is actually great
there's so many bad scripts out there
you know and that's fine I mean it's
really hard to write a good script but
um
I would say whenever you get terrible
notes just
try to be understanding probably the
other person's having a personal issue
you know maybe they're frustrated with
their career maybe things didn't work
out
because there's really no need to
destroy anyone's script
that's my my opinion
if we were going to take the same new
screenwriter and they asked well how do
I know I have a yes person who might be
reading my script so it's a person who
doesn't want to hurt my feelings or
maybe there's an agenda they want to
keep the friendship for whatever reason
how do you know how do you decipher
someone who's just giving you fluff you
mean professionally it's something
that's leading nowhere
um feedback on a script so it could be a
friend it could be a manager somebody
that just they just want to tell you yes
they want to keep you happy but it's
actually not constructive
um well what I would say is what do you
want from feedback you don't want I mean
of course our egos need you know a
little attention so when someone says I
loved your script it's so good there's a
second where you appreciate it because
you need validation but then there's
nothing you can do with that and if
you're honest with yourself you don't
really believe that your script is
perfect and I'm not saying that you
should work on it endlessly because
there comes a time when you have to stop
and you have to move on
and you know there's a fine line
um between rewrites and then just over
rewriting it
um of course unless you're getting paid
and then you have no choice
what I would say is you you try people
out first of all this intuition I
mentioned right so your intuition says
this person is mindful this this person
might understand what I'm trying to do
you know they're generous with their
time
because a lot of people are you know
they can be great individuals they're
not really generous
um because you know in order to read
someone's script you need to take time
to read it and take notes and actually
give them something back if you're just
going to read it in a hurry and and say
like oh my God you're such a good writer
great job
you haven't really done the work you
know you haven't really considered I
know my script is not perfect that's why
I gave it to you
so
um if you feel people out you try it
usually you know you know when they give
you notes you know that if it's going to
work out or not it's like you know next
time I think I'll go with someone else
because
um you actually want
um honest feedback like what did you
like what did you connect with
um what's working what's not working did
you find anything
um outlandish or outrageous some people
might even I mean
hopefully not but they might even get
offended like why are you offended are
you offended in a good way like is this
you know
um is this causing contradictions that
make you think or is this actually
offensive and you know I should
reconsider it
in terms of topics writer content
um so I think it's you know trial and
error and with time you find your people
with with reps
um well that's that's a whole different
chapter because reps I mean I've had
several over the years
and it's it's hard it's almost like a
like a you know like a love relationship
you gotta find your person
and um
agent I mean agents you don't expect
much in terms of creative
uh conversation with with an agent but
with a manager you can
um not always though sometimes your
manager's notes might be you know this
is not new enough I need something new
because they're trying to sell
and it's like well you know I don't
really know what to do with that what
does that mean
why do I know what new is
um
so you know that's it's different
because they're not your friend they can
be but I mean there's mutual interest in
that you produce something that sells
and they want to sell it
but with colleagues and friends I feel
like you know
you gotta sense it like okay this person
cares this person is generous
and a lot of people are not
unfortunately
you know it's a tricky thing and I don't
mean to contradict what you're saying
but with generosity I think that
especially maybe here in La there are a
lot of takers and I know that's not a
popular thing to say but I'm just going
to say it and so I think when people
they have to be guarded with their time
yeah that's the only thing I can throw
out about that um well you know I feel
like La is a double-edged sword in the
sense that
um you gotta be here because this is
where the opportunity happens and that
is still true even though last year when
the pandemic was at its worst I feel
like you didn't have to be here but
usually you do
um with meetings in person at least or
events you know events where you can
actually meet certain people and that's
tricky too because you know
uh the thing with networking I mean I'm
I'm uh you know transitioning to a whole
different chapter well the thing with
networking is that you don't just go to
parties and meet someone and get a job
you got to build a relationship and the
hardest part about La is actually
building meaningful relationships
um and it's about the work you produce
but it's also about a personal
connection that's real
you know people you know when you
actually like someone and they like you
back and you can have dinner
and you don't have to talk about work at
dinner you're just hanging out
but if you you know if you have
something to offer and they actually
like you and you like them
the odds are they're going to call you
so you know it's that it's not what you
do it's who you know well it is about
what you do but
um having a personal connection that's
real
doesn't hurt
sure I think that's where
it's a challenge yeah and it is true
look it is it is true that a lot of
people in this town are really desperate
so they are selfish but also I mean it's
really they're trying to make a living
you know
sorry I'm really trying to be
understanding with everyone like I
you can you know get you can get upset
uh and judge people and think they're
superficial or you know or that their
Ambitions are
um over the top you know but it is a
very competitive environment
um and people are just trying to get
jobs so
you know try to find your people and and
if someone is not
um your crowd then that's fine
sure and it's a very expensive place to
live and it's competitive
not just jobs but survival jobs
apartments everything so you're
constantly in this Loop of competition
waiting for something and so it's hard
to maybe the generosity it's not that
they don't want to help someone it's
just maybe they're all tapped out
I mean everyone's here to quote unquote
make it right and again whatever that
means and I say that because everyone's
careers have ups and downs right and
when you're at your lowest then maybe
the next day things just pick up
incredibly so even for Highly Successful
People nothing's guaranteed right you
might you know you might be incredibly
successful making a lot of money and
have a deal with uh Amazon or Netflix or
Apple
and then your show is a flop and then
you're vanished right so I mean
it's it's ups and downs
um
it's really hard to build meaningful
relationship in a town where everyone's
trying to find their Niche and trying to
you know find stability I'd say that the
worst thing about
um being a writer or a Creator is the
lack of stability
you know we all I think we all crave it
at some point that's why I like teaching
because it gives me a certain stability
and a certain steady income right
um there's nothing wrong with having a
plan B
for the times when things don't work out
even I mean even if you have writing
jobs contract negotiations can take
forever
and I'll never understand why because
I'm not involved in that part but they
might take months
so you're waiting on a you know on a
sure thing
and you're going to get paid and you're
going to have you know just have to sit
down and write but you know reps and
lawyers and and there's something going
on behind the curtain that you don't get
to see
and you just have to be patient
so either find a hobby or you know get
on a side gig you know I I love teaching
I love the interaction with students
um I've you know I've done educational
content I every once in a while I
started out by making film related
um content and then I ended up you know
this year I wrote units on ethics
um and Community for example and I
didn't expect that to happen that was
exciting
um yeah but it's an income it's
stimulating
I learn
so
you know you gotta open up like half
different
um Avenues
open
going back to what you said about
writing and it being hard I I think
you've posted that you like Gore Vidal
the author and I know he he's not
worried about uh offending anyone or
it's just saying what he feels and um
one quote I have here from him is some
writers take to drink others take to
audiences
[Laughter]
I don't know if many people nowadays are
um
I've read I mean first of all he's
incredibly prolific I can't believe that
man and by the way he's he's overlooked
in general he's um his whole take on
American history I mean he's written
about many you know
um relevant figures and periods of
American history and he's incredibly
talented and insightful I I especially
love his rivalry with William Buckley Jr
there's a documentary called best of
enemies and I think Aaron Sorkin at some
point was going to make that movie and I
would have loved to see that
um
I just enjoyed it all and um
I I envy or I'd say no I admire more
than Envy I admire how disciplined and
prolific he was
in terms of
um you know writing or any kind of uh
stimuli involved I I'm a get you know I
drink coffee and right you know
uh and in terms of audiences I I try not
to think too much about that because
you you know you might you might get
lost thinking about like who am I
writing for
uh you just try to be very personal and
very honest and hope for the best
that you know just hope that someone
cares
and one last follow-up quote from Gord
vadal
the four most beautiful words in our
common language
I told you so
[Laughter]
I mean look he was he was a pro guitar
so I mean I'm I don't know what he
actually means but I told you so which
is probably one of the worst things you
can tell anyone no one's no one ever
reacted well to that sentence right but
um
he did like to provoke a lot
um he liked confrontation
[Music]
actually you know I think Vidal and and
Buckley invented the the figure of the
pundit I don't think before 1968 when
they had those presidential debates
um journalists you know broadcasting uh
news was just it tried to be objective
the idea of having someone Express
opinions and debate it wasn't a thing
um so I think you know I admire of it
all as you know as a novelist uh as a
screenwriter as a playwright as a pundit
just one of those figures that I I find
in stimulating and I also admire his
intellect
what are three things every great story
has well I think
I want to be a little bit obvious here
but I think a great opening
uh you need a hook
especially nowadays that people are so
distracted and there's so much to read
and watch and
so a great hook a great opening that um
offers a question
Intrigue so I'll say that of course if I
say a great opening I have to say a
great ending
and usually I'd say when I write that's
those are the two things I think of
first I need to know where I'm starting
off from and I need to know where I need
to get to
and the beauty or the challenge is okay
how do I get from point A to point B
uh
but I'm going to say the third element
is a a great character or characters
uh I think one of the most difficult
things things to do is to find
characters that feel real or possible
and not just ideas but that feel like
people and that's why
the Temptation is always to steal from
someone you know and what I mean is
think of people in your life and you
know and you you never I personally I
don't ever do just one person I don't
I'm not trying to portray a single
individual
I'm taking different elements it's a
composite of different people
um
well the character I would say though
there has to be an emotional connection
and
with this I mean it's very easy to have
ideas and then apply them and the risk
with ideas is that you're not connected
to them they just sound great they sound
original
but if there's no emotional connection
to you you can sense it you feel it's
cold right it's it's too rational
so with character you I try to find that
emotional connection why do I relate to
this trait why are the certain quality
right
um
why do I want to keep seeing this why do
I want to write about this
so I'd say a great beginning a great
ending and at least one singular
memorable character
can you give me an example of a
character of film or television that
definitely seems real you could see them
once the movie ends they're still living
their life somewhere and then the
opposite one that
maybe was all hype but really it felt
one-dimensional
um
well I mean this is the the first the
first character I used this in class
because the way it's written it's it's
just
I'd say memorable is the word so uh With
The Big Lebowski the way it the way he's
into the character is introduced in the
script the way it's written and the way
we see it on screen is just that
we know that guy right I don't know him
I mean I don't know him exactly like
that but that that guy exists and he's
so la he's so Venice to be specific you
know and I don't we don't know how he
makes a living and he's funny and he's
high all the time and he's by the way so
he's at Ralph's at 3am in a bathrobe
with sunglasses and he pays for a carton
of milk with a check
right so it's like who is this guy I
know him he's just by looking at him I'm
laughing
and that's because I recognize that
character uh and he's memorable
so you know coin brothers are so good at
that
um but
if we take the graduate Benjamin in The
Graduate for example a totally different
character more grounded
I you know I recognize that guy as well
you know I'm sorry I'm just mentioning
male characters I'm sure I can find
female ones too but what I'm saying is
those are people I can relate to and if
I can relate to them it's because
they're specific enough you know and you
can come from a totally different that's
the beauty of of art you come from a
different culture a different background
and even different
um gender and you connect because you
know there's something about the human
experience that you see there
um I don't know if I can I remember the
quote but I you know David Lynch who I
was listening to on a podcast yesterday
said
um find the thing that by knowing it you
know all there is to be known and what
that basically means is if you capture a
little thing that's real you're
capturing truth in general and people
connect to that that sounds very
abstract but what it means is the more
specific you are with your characters
the more you know with what they like
what they don't like what they do how
they like their coffee you know and I
tell students this all the time ask as
many questions as possible
try to you know try to enjoy the process
of getting to know your characters as if
you were
um knowing someone you just met
and then the opposite
a character or characters that there was
a lot of hype around the film or the
television show but they fell flat to
you
that's a tricky one uh because I you
know I have to criticize someone's
um work I you know off the top of my
head I I don't know I can usually this
is the thing big franchises don't have
great characters because it doesn't
matter uh you know and I don't want to
be cheap and and so you know I enjoy the
Fast and the Furious movies because I do
I mean I I watch them they get more
bloated and more you know insane by by
the movie so
those are not really characters you know
they're tropes
and it you know it's okay because maybe
those movies don't need characters
I think that's you know that's a choice
I don't think that's an accident
you know action movies in general you
don't need characters to be too deep
right they just need to be resilient
and bleed and fight
we go back to the graduate Mrs Robinson
yeah was she was she three-dimensional
oh definitely well I mean there is no
movie without her right it's Benjamin
and Mrs Robinson and and this is what's
interesting when I first watched it I
think in my
probably as a teenager
um I don't think I understood her that
well as you get you know as you get
older you you get her predicament more
clearly it's like oh I you know I see
where she is in life I see why she feels
unfulfilled I see why she would flirt
with this youngster you know
um it's such a complex character and
um I feel like if you can get characters
to do anything and you can still
understand their motivation and their
contradictions and relate to them
then that's that to me is success
you talked about great openings have
there been excellent films that had kind
of weak openings or is that always
a through line great films great
openings
you can't have one without the other I'm
think I'm thinking I'm thinking I know
there are films
that take their time to get there
um
see the thing is I those are the ones I
forget great openings are memorable
um I always say that things you forget
are because not because you have a
problem you know maybe you have a
neurological problem but mostly the
things I forget is because they were not
memorable
and what's memorable memorable and
what's not that's another question but I
do know
um the you know
I I do know which openings I remember
every single time and that's because
they're great you know and I could say
for example the opening of uh Back to
the Future right I remember that exactly
why is it that you know that because
that's a perfect script in its own genre
right
the same with Indiana Jones I mean I
don't know even The Exorcist
the great openings are I'm talking
movies I could talk TV as well you know
Breaking Bad I mean all sorts of
examples but great openings are always
memorable
um the reason I can't think of any
negative examples is because I've
forgotten bad I mean there's really I
mean I have no need to Archive that you
know to save that in my in my brain
archive
because the ones I've been over and over
again are the ones uh that I take as
examples
where does the creation of a great story
begin I feel like
um every every creative has a different
um source of inspiration or motivation
um
maybe it's a feeling maybe it's an image
maybe it's a Memory maybe all of them
combined
um I usually to me there's usually an
image
um and that image is going to guide me
along the way
um when I feel lost in the story I go
back to that and that image usually
contains
at least one emotion
um that I don't maybe I don't fully
understand it
but I will explore that through the
story
so um
to me it's yeah I would say
an image or a series of images
um that contain in them the whole story
um and it's it's the most mysterious
thing because I
um
I can't fully explain it you know
suddenly I'll be talking to someone or
I'll be reading right something or
listening to music
to a song or and some or or someone will
tell me a story like you know the other
day I bought this doll and
um I gave it to my daughter and and
suddenly I hear this and there's there
are coordinates there that make me
resonate
and I know that because I keep thinking
about it
um
so if if after a couple of days I keep
thinking about it and I'm talking about
Original Stories no it's very different
if you get a commission like please
write this story right if it's an
original thing
um if I keep thinking about it
um
and especially if I can tie to that
other elements that I'm interested in
um you start building a world right
um and I know for example when Hitchcock
did South uh North by Northwest
there was no story originally he had a
series of scenes he wanted to shoot and
then he brought brought in Ernest Layman
who's one of the best writers ever and
then they came up with a story to tie
those scenes together but what he knew
at first is he had these images you know
a guy hanging from Mount um Rushmore
right so
um a guy shoots someone at the U.N
building
and that's perfectly okay you know of
course he's Hitchcock he knew everything
but
um and then you you tie those scenes
together and you have a story
um I like you know what Howard Howard
Suber uh who taught at UCLA for 50 years
but he calls by association which is
when you bring together two elements
that wouldn't necessarily uh coexist but
when you do something new comes out
right so um
and this happens in life all the time so
um for example I mean if you're shooting
underwater and you introduce I don't
know there's a fireplace down there I'm
being extreme it doesn't belong there
but with that trigger this is a series
of Connections mental connections right
where suddenly you have to make that
work
uh checkup did this in in theater all
the time right introducing an element
that doesn't belong and that that can
set the story in motion
um
so going back to your original question
I think it's images that have an
emotional backbone and I have to figure
out what that means to me
and then the story will very slowly with
patience come out
and one thing I'd like to say about that
is
um you got to be very careful because
you got to be patient with it
and also don't let it drag you know you
got to find a certain balance
because sometimes you just want to rush
it you're like you know I want to know
what the story is
and you'll have a lot of good ideas but
they're not necessarily clicking
so sometimes I'll do a very quick
um outline
and then I go back to it and realize
this stays this has to go you know this
is not really honest this is me trying
to get out of you know of this situation
quick enough to move on
um
it's a very organic process of discovery
you don't always have the luxury of time
I'm saying ideally if you do
you want to find a balance between
taking your time and not wasting time
is that normal
what's your story I mean if you feel
enough
you know of a pull toward it whether
it's about you personally or a character
that you really
um you know have fondness for new
writers if would you tell them that you
will feel lost writing your story oh
absolutely I mean I wish someone had
told me that you get lost you get lost I
mean I get lost very often
um and you get lost mostly not not
because you don't know what you want
mostly because
um
of expectations you know so sometimes
you have an intuition and that intuition
says something but you want to make it
so much better and so original and that
you keep pushing and suddenly you have
doubts
um and you have to try to go back to
that original impulse right
um
and again the more time you spend with
it the the more chances you'll get of
figuring it out but
um
this is the tricky to me see to me that
the most difficult thing is not the
writing itself it's figuring out what
you want to write the heavy lifting to
me is coming up with a story on the
characters and the beats
once I have all that writing is just a
joy
so the writing itself is not that that
complicated it's knowing what I have to
write
once I have that the story all mapped
out and the characters and I'm confident
because that gives me confidence and
once I once I'm confident I can actually
play with it
it's a joy but it's not easy
no I mean it's not easy but
um
it's like playing a sport
um only every time you you go out there
you have to learn the rules again once
you know the rules okay you know what
the options you have right and and you
come out certain place you come up in
the spur of the moment certain places
you have practiced before
um
what I'm saying is that it's not that
it's easy it's just what I'm confident
it's because I've done my homework and
when I've when I've got that in my head
then I can improvise you know a little
bit so I know the scene starts here and
ends here
um I'm gonna add a little flare here
that without extending myself too much
yes I can actually that little flare
might have a narrative purpose right
I'll give you a small example for
example I would
um I was writing this scene
and then where this character is trying
to impress this woman is trying to
impress an older woman who she sees as a
mentor right and they're at these older
woman's uh house
and the older woman says uh let's go
upstairs I want to show you something
but please would you mind taking your
shoes off
and I thought what if
she is a broken saw you know her sock is
torn right and it's so embarrassing
and at first I thought that's amazing
and then I thought well what is does it
fit into the story or am I
but I realize it's such a character
trait and it's such you know it's
there's a narrative purpose if you're
trying to impress someone you'll be very
embarrassed
so not only did it stay it made the
scene
or you didn't get a pedicure that week
and you're you're yeah your feet look
horrible anything that makes you look
you know other than what you want to be
perceived as right um
for you maybe her husband will say like
it's not a big deal honey and she'll be
like yes it is a big deal it might be
right some people it would be yeah well
if you think of me I'm like
she thought you were amazing
until she saw your foot
um so you know that's you gotta right
but that only comes out once you know
your world and your characters sure sure
and the relationships right I could see
that being a real thing I mean because
you go to people's homes all the time oh
do you mind taking off your shoes oh no
no problem and then you go oh that's
right and then you're thinking oh no
yeah what are you gonna think how didn't
I think of this in advance you know and
that makes the character real
what's your writing process my writing
process it starts off with a
procrastination and I gotta say this
because every writer does it
um and it's terrible I don't recommend
it
but no let's be honest
writing starts off with uh an idea right
um
and you get excited about this idea and
you have to write it down
again I'm talking about writing on spec
it's very different if you're coming in
to write something or you know if
there's a pre-existing
let's start off with writing on spec and
I'll answer the question separately if
you know about writing based on someone
else's material so if it's my own script
um there's an idea
and uh I'm very excited about it and I
need to write it down and I need to
capture it as best as I can right so I
uh usually might be on my computer or
might be just um I hadn't written right
and I'll take a notebook and I'll start
writing
um
and of course I'm very satisfied with
that but then you realize okay this idea
is not the story right everyone has a
great idea but then you have to break
down break it down into characters and
beats and it's so much more complex and
of course it will change because I I D
great ideas don't make great movies they
can help but great movies need events
right and conflict and characters and so
on
um so you start breaking at some point
you start breaking down the story you
get very frustrated because now it's
real right ideas are up there flying in
the air but then you're breaking it down
and now it's got it's gotten real
so you start breaking it down
um
and you explore characters separately
and if some people do backstory
I discover backstory as I go along
some people start off from theme I Love
Theme by the way it's something I think
about I tend to think of theme as a
question
you know some people some people will
use words right like um
Love full potential right
I don't know what to do with with those
words and you know in terms of practical
writing like it's a story about love
sure I mean but what do I do with that
so to me themes are more more of a
question more of a specific question
um you know it might be a movie about
sports but then the theme is
um how does it feel like to not be
recognized by your father right for
example so I mean it's something I can
relate to and then I can explore and the
story is an answer to that question in a
way
so
um once I have the idea I start breaking
down separately character and backstory
um
the world right
um if it's period I have to do research
and I love research
I actually love it so much that I would
spend my entire life just doing research
I I love going reading books watching
movies going to library you know
sometimes great the New York Public
Library has an amazing archive and you
go there in the back with your little
gloves and then you just spend hours
going through original letters and
I I had a blast doing that so research
not too much because at some point it
can drive you mad so at some point you
got to stop with research and start
I'm making things up
and once you have like the world the
characters the beats and now you're
ready to start writing
um if it's you know if it's based on
someone else's material then
[Music]
um
well I guess instead of coming up with
the Beats you're trying to find those
beats in the book or the source material
and
the characters the beauty of adaptations
is that characters are given
you know still it doesn't mean that
you're going to take everything in there
you gotta learn what to take and what to
discard of course
um a friend who's a producer the other
day was telling me that um movies are
not novels movies are short stories
um and and short films are like poems so
you know there's not a lot of beats in a
movie even if you're doing a three hour
long movie there's not an infinite
amount of Beats novels have so much
material that you gotta weed out what
stays and what goes
um
so it might seem like you have a lot of
you know um real estate to to develop
your story but you don't
an average 100 minute movie is I'd say
about 36 to 40 Beats
maybe maybe more if it's really
fast-paced but you only have a certain
amount of seams in a 90-minute script
you know you have 33 minute scenes again
it's not math but you know what I'm
saying is you really gotta pick what
you're gonna focus on
it doesn't matter if it's an adaptation
on your own work
for your script regarding Timothy Leary
since he had such a vast long life
sure when he passed away he took his
life correct he died in the eye in the
late 90s he was already
um
in his 80s okay
how did you know what you what time
period or did what did you cover most of
it well actually it took me several
drafts to figure that out
um I knew it had to start in the 60s
the first draft I wrote of the script
started in 1963 which is when he gets
kicked out of Harvard
uh because he gave students uh
psilocybin and LSD
um but then I realized I had to go back
I had to start it off in 1960 which is
when he gets hired at Harvard Harvard
because it's he's 40 years old uh he's
going through a middle-aged age crisis
his wife first wife has just committed
suicide recently no one knows about this
so I figured you know I gotta start at
the beginning
and sometimes it's not easy to know
where the beginning is
um it's really up to you
so I actually wrote I think like two
drafts that took place in 63
and then I went back to 1960 which is
the current version
um
and then the beauty of it is you can
have at least five or six seasons if you
wanted because every stage of his life
is a different whole different thing
Harvard California New York
Afghanistan Switzerland you know
[Music]
um
but only I mean I wrote the first draft
based on the book and then I went to the
public uh library in New York where
there are approximately
463 I think boxes of his belongings wow
his personal archive
and I you know I rifled through that and
I didn't get to All the Boxes by the way
because that's Insanity
um I did go through a lot of them over
several trips
and you know it was
there's nothing I like better than
spending time with you know studying
original sources
right and then he had a subsequent
relationship
with someone that he cared very deeply
for didn't he but it's debatable whether
she was
hired
to spy on him
um oh there was a documentary that came
out recently by Errol Morris I think
it's his fourth wife Joanna Harcourt
Smith
um Leary had several wives
um
well there was a whole debate I had with
the producer who was uh who's a friend
of mine and who was convinced that Lee
was a saint
and I had to tell him um no he was this
man was incredibly flawed
very responsible
um we I think he's our way into the
Counter Culture and telling that whole
story I don't think we should use this
man as an example of anything
because he for for decades he talked
about the death of ego and he had
nothing but ego actually he was married
to I think five amazing women and he
disrespected all of them and he could
never you know he could never love them
the way they loved him and it's actually
tragic I know I mean I hope none of the
fans hilarious fans are listening
because they're going to kill me but
um I think he's a very contradictory man
um very you know he had the he had the
charm he could lure people in
um he's very smart
um but I think the the the one in that
relationship the one who actually
transcended all that was Richard Alpert
who became ramdas
so in the show we have uh Leary who's uh
who's a voice of this whole movement but
in a way I feel like he's disingenuous
and you have ramdas who actually did go
to India and transcend ego and became
this beautiful being
can you explain how you outline a
screenplay yeah so outlines
um
I'd say so first you have the idea right
or you have the the concept so to speak
um and some people have high Concepts
you know like
um which are easier to explain in in a
few words
um I usually have low Concepts in the
sense that they're character driven and
that's in a way it's more challenging
because you gotta find out what makes
them distinctive from other ideas you
know the maybe the juice the beauty of
it is not in the concept but in in the
world in the character
so um
I I do a beat sheet first
um and I use an exercise that uh Hal
Ackerman talks about who I had class
with a UCLA called snow plowing and snow
plowing is basically
um you set out a certain amount of time
could be 20 minutes could be 40 or an
hour usually you don't do more than an
hour at a time
and um you write down possible scenes
without judging them and not not
stopping right so it doesn't matter if
they contradict one another you just
keep going
so um because they're just possibilities
they're not the whole final thing
um and ideally you you know you write I
don't use a computer then I just write
it down
um manually and
let's say you do 20 minutes and you just
go non-stop don't because if you stop
you're gonna judge it and the point is
not to judge yourself the point is to
discover
so you do this exercise a few times over
and over again and then you go back to
it and then you pick and discard like
okay this is good this one not you know
doesn't work or I'm gonna just pick this
option
um and I'd say after a few times of
doing that you start having a sense of
what the structure is
um of course you can also guide yourself
with with uh books right now save the
cat has as an option of what a structure
is
I mean I feel like intuitively you know
that your structure needs
um ups and downs and and beats of all
kinds and you kind of have a midpoint
um so by doing by snow plowing and then
by going back to the idea of structure
you come up with a beats and once you
have the Beats which are the bones the
outline is like giving that connective
tissue right so
um once I'm confident about my beachy
then I just start filling out
um those bones with yeah with flesh
which is not too much detail but enough
detail to connect the scenes and make
sure that there's a cause and effect
relationship between them
um and you just expand
um
so I would say there's I mean I don't
skip any of the steps you know from idea
I go to beat sheet from beachy I go to
outline
um I don't need my outlines to be too
detailed I just need them to have the
necessary information especially if I
want to have like setups and payoffs I
want to make sure those are in the
outline
um and then you just start writing
when you're writing these scenes that
you don't want to judge and they might
be random scenes
are they ones you've already had in your
mind or are you almost manufacturing
them so that the most
you know ridiculous idea like this would
never really happen and then once you go
back and look at it you think well
actually we could lead to that
no the point is to to surprise yourself
actually
um
so I you know it's a very different the
creative mind that you apply is very
different you know you have like your
right side of the brain and your left
side of the brain right and I feel like
most of the time in the real world we're
we're being very rational
um so if you start writing from that
perspective you're going to come up with
probably conventional ideas and there's
nothing wrong with cliches by the way I
think they're a great starting point
when you don't know what to do just
write down the cliche so you can get it
out of the way
that's better than nothing
and sometimes I feel we get blocked
because you know you try to write the
most original thing ever
and you don't do that right away it's
really hard so maybe it's easier to
write a cliche and then you know maybe
change a few things and and maybe let it
evolve and turn or you know for example
I I always want to set a scene in the
most original location right
so instead of setting it at the
character's house which would be the
obvious thing because they're going to
discuss something intimate what if
they're in church right and that of
course makes the conversation more
awkward and maybe funny and they can't
really talk
great but is that does it serve the
story you know you don't want to be
eccentric just for the sake of being
eccentric
um but maybe maybe you plan the scene in
the character's house and then once you
have it okay what if I change the
location
you know and maybe and maybe it works
but you don't you don't go all the way
at once you know you want to take it
gradually and once you have it okay if I
change location would she say this in
public
if she said this in public maybe it's
funny maybe it's ridiculous I don't know
um
sorry I got lost in my my own logic
there oh yeah so originality I feel like
it's desirable to be original and you
don't want to be lazy
but sometimes some scenes can only take
place in one location right I mean if
the character is in prison they're not
infinite options right if someone's
visiting they can only meet in the
visiting space right there's no other
option
um but if you have time and and you know
and and and you want to make it better
maybe explore with certain scenes
unexpected locations
can you give me examples of these
cliches
what's a cliche uh well I mean with
characters it's easy because uh
stereotypes and archetypes right
um and we see this all all the time so
um
you know the cop the preacher the
prostitute right uh the bossy wife
um you don't want to play those
characters exactly the way it as they
sound because we've seen that and it's
boring and
um if if the audience is smart let's not
underestimate the audience the audience
has seen a lot of movies read a lot of
books whatever they know
so um if you're gonna play with
stereotypes or archetypes you better
find a way to make them slightly
different
or maybe start you know
Tony Soprano right Tony Soprano is a
gangster that goes to therapy if he was
just a gangster they'll be like okay
I've seen Good Fellas you know what's
why am I even watching this but Tony
Soprano has an issue again I'm going to
you know very classic example but
he has an emotional issue he's a
gangster you know and now it doesn't
surprise us but back in the day with The
Sopranos what 95 96 I don't know when it
came out
it was it was an amazing concept
um you know and sometimes I'm you know
it happened to me I have to write
gangsters so what do I do with gangsters
what haven't I seen with gangsters
I don't know gangster singing gangsters
crying what can I do with them
gangster that doesn't want to be a
gangster but has to swearsed by his
family yeah or her family yeah that
could lead somewhere
um as long as you can find
to me the most difficult thing is
finding the yeah the emotional
connection and by emotional I don't mean
I have to laugh or cry all the time it's
just that it resonates
um that it makes them three-dimensional
human
and that that your intuition says this
is something that a lot of humans could
relate to right that I
um
it's just that's you know it's
since writers are usually very smart as
as as a teacher as an instructor used to
tell me in grad school the smartest
people in the room
um
we have a lot of ideas and I don't mean
that in a good way uh ideas are are a
problem because
um you might
um get away with them and there's
nothing in you there it's just you know
we have we have stored all these ideas
and like well what if you know the what
if the cops suddenly decides to rob the
bank
sure sounds fun but what's what's in
there that you care about
yeah why do you relate to that
because he's having a crisis you know
about his identity and his profession
well now we're on to something then it's
not about robbing the bank it's about
what if a cop no longer believes in the
law because he thinks the system is
crooked I don't know I'm making this up
okay that's actually interesting
tell me more
so I feel like um yeah it's about
finding your personal connection
okay so we we know some some cliche
character archetypes what about scenes
what are some things you see students do
or maybe you did in the beginning that
they were too cliche whether it's
showing up at the best friend's wedding
and you know you know does anyone here
object and then you know just what the
typical
romantic comedy I would say
um
scenes about couples arguing
tend to lead to a lot of cliches
um
especially if you just play them out
very dramatically and I'm not saying
couples don't have very dramatic
arguments because they do
but what if you introduce certain
elements in there that makes suddenly a
scene
different and I'm going to quote on this
Phoebe Water Bridge
um
she said something that I loved and it
blew my she's such an amazing everything
but she said I always have to try to
have three different conflicts happening
to the character at the same time and
they're all not of the same magnitude so
for example
she needs to get an abortion it's very
hot in the room and she doesn't like how
her hair looks
so she's trying to figure out or tell
her significant other that she needs to
get an abortion while checking herself
in the mirror while also noticing that
she has sweaty armpits
so she writes comedy mostly so that I
can see how that can be a dramedy right
it's very dramatic but it's also very
funny because she's distracted
so if the scene were just her saying we
need to talk I'm pregnant and I need to
get rid of the baby okay sure that can
be a compelling scene but it's also
I don't know if you play that way it's a
bit conventional
but if she's concerned about her hair
then
that sounds very human
and she's seeing that she's sweating
yeah and she's wondering did the Barista
see me this sweaty and disgusting
there's so many options and she feels
like oh my God I'm pregnant I don't want
to be pregnant I'm gross you know like
Ugh I've never felt so ugly I wish my
hair was like straight you know so sure
I I think that's that's great advice
and it's your brothers
[Laughter]
I'm just saying
okay
um
just that that would take the cliche
that would also spin it you know you
know what's interesting though that
opens up because I have this
conversation this morning about tone and
I feel like
um tone is such an important uh element
in a story and um
it's something I do think about right
away even though I can't I don't think I
can avoid it tone
um is really hard to Define what it is
but you recognize it right and most of
the creators or filmmakers we love have
a very specific tone like the coin
Brothers have a very specific
kind of ironic sarcastic
almost sometimes almost depressing tone
you know it's about plot it's about
character you don't really know where
it's at but it's you can sense it
um
and I was I was breaking down a story
today actually and um
I followed the story through where it
led me and at some point it led to a
very dark area
that I got scared of
and by the way I would say getting
scared of something is a good sign
because you know it says it means
there's something
very personal to explore
but at the same time I felt it was so
dark that it destroyed my tone
you know and I got worried I would lose
my audience
that's one of those moments where you
feel like if I cringe
and not in a an interesting way you know
maybe it's worth considering
that direction
and I think it's a valid point sure so
you know that you kind of took it too
far and it wouldn't work for the story
um well I don't mind telling you what it
is because I'm not going to use it I
mean I had I had a character with a
situation and she's trying to figure out
how she feels
and why she feels so uncomfortable about
what's happening to her right and she
doesn't know
which is I mean it's odd it's not a
story where it's you know she's trying
to get money and no the goal of the
characters to figure out why she feels
the way she feels right it's a situation
triggered a feeling and she doesn't
understand it
and it's a very odd thing I mean I don't
know why I do this to myself because
it's not something tangible first of all
you got to be really careful do I want
to talk about this subject am I
qualified to talk about it does it
actually resonate with me or does it
just sound you know like it would have
an impact
and my gut feeling was like don't go
there
don't go there because once you
introduce certain topics the story is
done unless you want to discuss the
consequences of that and I don't want to
be the person doing that
you know and because I haven't been
through it and I I hope it doesn't
happen to me and I gotta be respectful
but if my tone is kind of playful you
got to be really careful where you go
some things are just not going to be
funny that's a good point you know no
matter how you approach it sure it's not
funny sure like the vibe is dead yeah
yeah because then you can't from that
point on it can be around comedy it
can't be another element in your story
yeah you either make your story about
that because you actually will have
something to say or refrain from it you
know but that you know that's I mean I I
want to be really careful not everything
is material for storytelling unless you
know like Michaela Cole who did I may
destroy you and you know the show is
about that but she went through it
yeah yeah the only thing I could think
of is that if you showed the character's
life up until that point that was light
and fun
and then if something horrible happens
and then how their life changes
drastically after that but yeah you
can't continue but the story then is
about that and by the way I'm not
against horrible things happening to
your character I mean I'm just saying
their their boundaries to me
um and there are things that I haven't
experienced that I mean I'd rather not
talk about
what writing process do you teach your
students
I try to teach my students give them as
many different tools as possible
um I don't believe in any Darkness I
don't believe there's one single way to
do it
um when I teach
so for example I have a whole class for
a three-hour class for structure and I
give give them all the approaches I know
to structure like the you know the save
the cat approach to it the Blake Snyder
approach to it uh the eight sequence
structure whatever it's whatever helps
they find helpful to break so it's not
so daunting to break down story because
um we all feel it you know when you when
you're facing the story you're like oh
my God I have so much ground to cover
and I don't know
so for example the eight sequence
structure is really helpful because
you're thinking in terms of 12 15 pages
at a time
um so you're you know you're writing
shorts I'm talking about features of
course
um
it's like writing uh short units
um and then by thinking of units you're
not thinking about the whole thing
um
with um with TV well TV I mean there is
there are multiple ways to do TV but um
you know I do give them I do compare TV
structure with film structure in the
sense that a drama pilot you know the
end of the teaser
is usually the inciting incident
um the end of act
um one
is where it kind of gets personal so the
the end of act two would be the midpoint
in a 60 Minute 55 minute
um pilot
um but I you know I I don't believe
there's one way to do things like
whatever works for each person
do you ever find students challenge that
because they've they've read books
before they've taken your class or
they've taken other classes and they say
well no this is actually how it's done
and they like those rules they like
structure
I I do believe there should be structure
I mean they don't usually question me
because they understand that I'm I'm
very straightforward from the beginning
and I said look I'm going to give you
um everything I know
and sometimes you know there are
different options but
I'm
no I mean they're adults so I'm giving
them an option it's like I'm not going
to tell you there's one single way to do
it I'm going to tell you all the ways I
found out over the years and some of my
colleagues prefer this version and
others this one
and um you know it's my my role as an
instructor is to give them tools not to
give them the ultimate truth because
there's no such thing
actually I would say the most important
thing
I don't know if you can teach people how
to write you can teach them discipline
you can encourage them you can show them
that it's not impossible
um
you can share experience you know
experiences that that reveal that you
can get frustrated and keep going you
can have failures and get up
um it's amazing how many times everyone
including myself and everyone else we
tend to think that what happens to us is
only happening to ourselves
and it's ridiculous because it's very
[Music]
um
liberating to hear that other people
have gone through the same
actually you don't all you don't you
never get you rarely get a chance but if
you can read first drafts by acclaimed
writers which of course you'll never
find because they don't want you to
but um Academy Award
writers winning writers also have awful
first drafts they also have scripts that
don't work
um you know it's it's not that they sit
down and write the most perfect script
ever it takes many rewrites
so I mean I know Aaron Sorkin will go on
and say like he wrote uh The Social
Network in three months
and like maybe I don't know you know I'm
sure he's very talented and smart and
qualified I'm saying you know we all
need time to get there
this is something that's hard for you
students to accept or or was that
something for you in the beginning that
you just wanted to get this idea out
there these characters out there you
didn't want to have to do multiple
drafts
um you mean if if they challenge the
idea of of rewrites sure or did you
yourself challenge it
um I well when I started out
um I had some resistance to rewrites
um
and it's important to understand that
when you resist it it's because you're
scared of it uh
and I would say it is
it is scary because
um the first draft once you understand
that the first draft is not the final
product
um it's just your first approach to it
um
then you understand that the rewrites is
where it actually gets tricky
um
and you know there are many
ways to approach rewrites
um it took me a while to learn how to do
it as well
I usually use the image it's it's like a
wound you know it's a scar that you're
reopening
and being very dramatic here but you
know you finish the draft and you're
very pleased and you want to step back
right and take some distance and then
you go back to it and you have to reopen
the wound like
it's all bloody again
and then you have to stitch it up again
um I I think that's when you need
perspective the most that's when you
could use feedback from close people
um conversations maybe even the help of
a script doctor at some point why not
it's really hard to have perspective on
your own writing
sometimes you need some time to go buy
maybe weeks or a month before you dive
in again
um and you need someone's perspective to
know what works and what doesn't and and
maybe you love a scene and that scene
needs to go
and you need someone to tell you that
scene needs to go
um the good thing about working for hire
or working with with uh with people is
that they actually give you
notes
um
and I could spend hours talking about
notes themselves and sometimes they'll
give you the best notes and it hurts
because you have to work a lot on them
but they're good notes you can tell
and sometimes you gotta find the note
behind the note
you know some you don't you can't expect
people always to have the perfect note
to give you but it's your job to find
out what they mean
um and also I you know I try to be very
careful when someone has one opinion
okay I'll see if I consider or not but
when one note keeps coming up over and
over again
in different manners right but it's the
same note
well then there's a problem
right when I a script I have to read
right now that I rewrote a couple of
times
it's a period script and um a note I
kept getting back was
the main character is an
why do I care
and at first I resisted saying like no
it's the 60s that's how people did
things back then
but then you know when I keep getting
the same note especially from female
readers they're like no that guy's an
well then I have a problem because I'm
not making a movie for the 60s I'm
making a movie for nowadays
so even though I'm trying to be very
accurate in terms of how I portray the
period my audience is now
so I got to do something about it
so you had to make the character
somewhat more relatable and human
to today's standards not
um 60s well I mean he's a guy who's
focused on
on his work and is is
um disregarding his he's very young his
wife is also very young and they have a
baby so instead of
being a good father which he can't
because he's like he's too young he
doesn't know I mean it's not how he
means
anything by it he just doesn't know how
to do it so he escapes family his
family's responsibilities by focusing on
his work
um and the note was he's being an
I'm like no well he's a kid you
know he doesn't know he shouldn't have
been a dad in the first place it's 60s
back in the 60s you didn't share that
responsibility they're like no I don't
care you know I don't care how good he
is at his job
he left her alone to raise a child
and you know there's really no point in
me arguing that
what about Don Draper
well
this is the thing I I love Mad Men and I
love Don Draper and I used that as a
reference
Don Draper only works for today's
audiences because Jon Hamm is really
sexy
okay that's fair enough uh yeah I
remember
back when it came out I was watching it
with my girlfriend at the time and
I would say you know he's he's
disgusting he's he's an awful person and
she would be like I don't care he's too
hot
and you know what there's a point there
I don't know how that they got that that
show made before casting
I think it took a while
um
yeah he's awful he's a broken man but
he's John Hamm in a suit
you have read like hundreds of
screenplays correct when you've interned
to these production companies probably
yeah what does that teach you about
writing and what came across your desk
it's the best advice I could give any
writer if you don't learn how to write
read Scripts
Read Bad scripts which is what you'll
mostly do read good scripts as well but
um there's no better way to write than
reading scripts
um see how different people use the
language on the format some people are
more verbose some people are very sparse
in in descriptions
um some people are really great I mean
scripts are not literature they're not I
mean they have to be engaging but
they're not novels so if you can be very
concise
and can convey the idea in a Snappy way
in one sentence those scripts really
work
of course I mean some people have you
know great prose but they're not there's
not a great story there it's it's so
difficult because you know it's it's a
conjuncture of great story uh great
characters great use of subtext right
there are many many scripts are marred
by the by characters just stating
everything how they feel and sometimes
you got to do that but
using subtext you know good use of sub
subtext it's very it's always
appreciated
we most of the time people are not we
don't go through life saying everything
we feel or think actually in order to
avoid conflict we tend not to right
um
especially I was talking about couples
you know couples don't say everything to
each other otherwise they would break up
or get divorced right away
so you make a scene about something else
uh anyway
um reading scripts helps you understand
the format and any doubts you might have
about format like how do I structure a
phone conversation well scripts that do
that teach you
um use of language how to be precise and
concise
[Music]
um
how to start scenes and end them
you know some people will just surprise
you
um
every once in a while try to read great
scripts by
recognized writers as well I mean the
the script for unforgiving Clint
Eastwood's movie is that's a novel I
mean I wouldn't use it as it's it's an
amazing script
um it's just you know the script itself
is epic
um I remember the script for
um Nightcrawler
uh is an amazing script the movie I
don't I'm not that crazy about but the
script itself there's a use of fonts in
the script that was really original
it changes the size and type of font
just to give you an impression of La at
night and the neon signs
and the descriptions in it are perfect
that's you know Nightcrawler is a
perfect script
um to analyze at least
so um read read reading bad scripts when
you're into an intern or production
company and you read bad Scripts
it's it boosts up your you know your
confidence because you tell yourself I
can do so much better than this and this
script not to talk bad about anyone but
I'm saying this script made it this far
especially I remember once I was shocked
reading a script that was terrible
written in five minutes and it had typos
very important just check you know check
grammar and spelling
typos are really distracting
and everyone will tell you this you know
it shows it's not everyone makes
mistakes it's just typos show that you
don't care you know you didn't care
enough to check and you can even use
software to check that
so
um reading scripts just you know it
helps you tune your mind into what it is
writing a script
do you think most new writers are overly
hard on themselves or they have the
opposite where they think it's brilliant
I think most writers are really hard on
themselves
um
of course you'll meet a few people that
will say they're brilliant
a I don't know if they actually believe
it and B if they actually believe that
oh my God they're you know I I don't
envy them because they're gonna
um hit their head against the wall at
some point
um I'm not saying people can't be
brilliant of course they're
and they're in their uh Natural Born
storytellers I've met a few
it's just that you know I I don't I
don't think it's a good idea to go
through life thinking you're brilliant
sooner or later you know it's gonna hurt
it for all of us
but it hurts too to think you're not
brilliant
and in fact you're the opposite so
um you know I think we it's it would be
good to avoid extremes you know like at
some point I mean the the older I get
and I'm not really that old but the
older I get I realize
um what helps and what doesn't help you
know and
what's useful
is it useful to think I'm brilliant no
is it useful to think I'm an idiot no
um
is it useful to think that this is the
best I I'm doing the best I can and that
it's probably going to be good enough
because this is what I can offer and if
they don't like it it's because maybe I
wasn't the right person for the project
Maybe
um
and of course I say this very calmly now
and then I'm writing the script and I
will say to myself like oh my God this
is awful
I wish I could do better
um
and I will or I will also tell myself
this is my best writing and then you
know you know what's funny um
many times I thought I did my best
writing and no one connected with it and
other times I had a deadline and I wrote
it very fast I thought oh my God this is
embarrassing
and people loved it
so
whatever opinion you have of yourself
I wouldn't I would try not to take
yourself too seriously
in general in life I like that so you
avoid extremes because it also applies
to dealing with other people too oh no
I'm very extreme I'm saying what I wish
I did
uh I you know I try to I try to be
mindful about it um I don't always
succeed
sure sure I mean we all want to sort of
live in the gray but yeah I mean ideally
if I could choose I would choose to be
aware as aware as they can it's in the
moment as I can and this has nothing to
do with writing by the way this is life
I mean
um I feel like there's so many labels
that I put on myself and then everyone
puts on one another you know and and
you're meant to
uh categorize yourself and especially
like what do you write oh I write period
dramas you know like well
that's not true that's what I'm doing
now I don't think that's what I'm gonna
do forever
um and it doesn't help you know I know
they they need to be able to label you
so that they can hire you and add it so
you know I'm I'm not trying to start a
revolution like you know I am who I am
but
um
if you have to label yourself to get a
job to it but internally I try not to
label myself
I try to be a better writer every day I
try to expand my interests and my scope
you know and if someday I can write a
rom-com why not I mean I don't know
when you worked at these production
companies interning out of the hundred
screenplays
how many were awful
uh I'd say about
more than 90 percent are awful or no I'm
mean mean I'd say more than 90 are bad
um
maybe 40 are awful
I mean because I mean you got to get
people credit
really bad scripts don't necessarily
make it up the ladder because you know
you got assistance and their job is
their Gatekeepers precisely so
um what I mean scripts are bad
it doesn't necessarily mean they're
badly written it means that you know
they're conventional full of cliches
um
maybe you know maybe they stick to genre
um and um and they don't transcend it in
any way
um lazy in terms of ideas
but I mean it doesn't mean that doesn't
mean they're not potentially commercial
products so I don't think that
um people in charge of of choosing don't
have any taste or or can't discern what
I think is that um you know they're
trying to find something that sells
and if you check Netflix 10 most watched
shows or they're not necessarily good
again I'm not trying to be the judge of
what's good or bad I mean
I try to be entertained but also
stimulated and I want to think and I
want to feel I mean
some people just need you know come back
from work they hate what they do and
they want to watch something that takes
their mind off it and it works
sure and there are some networks that
cater to that and they're very
predictable stories and outcomes and and
people feel safe in watching that that's
what they want it is look it is a
business and and
um I think most of the people involved
in in Show Business are very smart
um I'm I don't think execs are you know
bureaucrats I think they're some of them
went to you know Harvard and Yale and
whatever and they're really educated and
smart it's just it's a business so you
know most of the shows big networks are
gonna put up are probably
easy to digest
I I get it it's not what I watch but
then again I don't represent the larger
population
that's a good point so
the ones that were really awful probably
wouldn't have made it that far in the
process but you say 40 ish
maybe we're bad so then 60 were great or
then there was a gray area where some
were not horrible no the percentage of
great scripts is really small
so great I mean let's say good
let's say I'm generalizing let's say
between eight to ten percent of the
scripts are actually good
great
maybe two percent okay one percent wow
it's really hard to find a great script
it's really hard to write a great script
um that's why certain you know
I don't know Shauna Rhimes did Gray's
Anatomy it's what it's the 14th 15th
season
of course then eventually she came up
with other shows but she's been work she
was working on that show for many years
and that was one great script that got
it all started
um it's really hard to replicate success
you know some people
The Simpsons right yeah sure they did
Futurama and you know some other
attempts but the Sims is all the
Simpsons so it's really really hard to
write a great script it's really hard to
find the people willing to take risks to
produce it and get it made
Queen's Gambit you know big success what
last year it took 10 years to get that
made
um I remember meeting the the guy who
wrote Dallas Buyers Club that movie took
20 years to get made
I'm not saying that's okay and I'm not
saying that's the standard I'm saying
you gotta be ready to know that things
take a long time
unless unless you want to go out there
and make a really small movie
self-financed or through you know
crowdfunding or something like that
which isn't easy either
um and a lot of people do it and hope
that it clicks you know and I I can
think of the examples where that helped
um
what's it called a woman walks home at
night
alone yeah alone at night so um
she was at UCLA before I I was in uh um
I don't remember the director's name
Lily um Iranian so um she went out there
and made that movie and it got an
audience and she has a career and yeah
good for her yeah I'm poor or lily yeah
yes so you know a few examples like that
um
but even you know back in the day
Sundance was like the way in and now
Sundance is so commercial and so
oversaturated that if you make a movie
by yourself I mean I don't even know if
you can find a spot
there
yeah it's probably become a much
different uh ball game and then some of
those movies then play other festivals
and it's kind of like all the same
movies
going to these festivals and it's yeah I
mean I'm I don't even want to get into
the whole sure thing because
um you know as a former film critic I
know that world very well sure uh and I
have opinions about festivals but
um yeah we can stay away I I get it no I
think I think that um writing a good
script takes a couple of
not even months I'd say a year maybe two
of rewrites
um maybe know what you know what you
want to say and then you can get it done
in six months I don't know
would you read every one of those
screenplays from start to finish
when I when I had to read them yeah when
you're working as an intern at these
Productions ah yes yes I
um well first of all I had to
um because when you do coverage
um coverage basically exists so the
people above you don't have to read
those scripts unless they have to
so what you're doing is you're
summarizing you have to give them a log
line a synopsis maybe a short synopsis
and then a longer one of the story of
the whole story
um and then say the pros and cons and
you know and and choose if you're
passing or considering or recommending
and of course everyone's really scared
to recommend because then your taste and
your job is on the line
right so you got to be re most of the
times you'll say pass
uh and this you know
because
you really want to make sure if you
recommend something it's that good
uh I as an intern I did take chances
though and there were no consequences
but it it would happen that they would
come to me and say okay so tell me more
what did you see in it I want to hear
you you know so
um you got to have an opinion and by the
way this is really helpful as a writer
it is but if if you want to be an exec
someday or a producer you better have
opinions and you better be able to
express them
in an articulate way
um as a writer not so much I did it I
did it to learn mostly and get
experience
so you were working with producers would
they also then read the script from back
to front or if you can if you suggest
they consider it or even if you
recommend it
maybe not themselves their assistants
will I don't know necessarily but um
you're basically saving them time
um
but if you waste their time you won't be
there much longer
because if they had to read and hate it
and this is you know it's part of the
business
sure what if your tastes are just edgier
and you like something that's more of an
art film and they're looking for a
feel-good relationship story well I
would say is if you're entering on a
company do your research on their
mandate so you know if they do horror
and you're and and they get for any
number of reasons you know a romantic
story with no horror whatsoever because
you never know and you know maybe maybe
the the son of someone they know wrote
the script and sent it I don't you never
know how that works
it's not for them you know it's not
their mandate
unless you can ask them like hey I got
the script it's really weird it's not
really your mandate do you want me to go
on with it and they'll say yes please
read it anyway I see so you're going to
check if something is not sort of in
their wheelhouse you'll check with them
you should be yeah so Blum House right
that's horror everyone knows that so if
you have a you know Thriller with spies
it might be a great script it's probably
not and by the way blood house doesn't
spend more than three to five million
per movie
so you're going to do your homework you
know they're not the right company for
it
maybe it's a great script and you tell
them hey by the way this is not your
mandate but it's a great script okay
we'll send it over to our friends
somewhere else and they always a
favorite I don't know
you know but it makes you look good to
know what their mandate is
sure sure but if you're recommending
stuff that's just then they're gonna sit
you down and you know
why are you sending us it didn't happen
to me I'm just imagining I mean sure
um you got to know what your role is as
well you know
and as an intern you don't have a lot of
power
how many of the screenplays that you
read went on to be films
less than 10 probably
um supplement is a thing some of them I
I knew were already going to get made uh
some of them you know you knew you knew
they were going around town so it's not
like only the production company had
that script
uh and you could tell you know I
remember there was a script about the
Kelly gang in Australia
um that movie was obviously ready to get
shot
I mean it was so I don't even know what
they they made me read it maybe because
they wanted to invest in it
um
but it didn't feel like someone sent
that you know on spec that was ready to
go
um
I'm trying to remember
there were amazing scripts I read that
didn't get made and I'm surprised
oh you know which which script I read
and I haven't seen the movie yet the one
with um Michael Keaton worth that just
came out recently about the 911 lawyer I
read that script oh yes that was great
so I read that script in uh 2016. I just
watched that and they just got right he
got made 2020 I think
right yeah that was so you know
two four to five years
that's not that bad actually but you
know it takes a while
so you said there were a few that were
excellent that didn't get made
yeah I'm I'm trying to remember I
remember an amazing script about uh Anne
Frank and um
the woman in New York who got the book
published
uh for the first time in the 40s I think
or maybe early 50s so how the
the manuscript was discarded at first
and this this junior editor a woman who
she wanted to become an editor the woman
who discovered the book and said hey
wait a minute this is actually uh
relevant
um that script I remember reading it and
I got very emotional about it and that's
really hard to do it's really hard to
get an emotional reaction from a script
I mean if you're gonna make people laugh
that's good that's a lot if you can make
people teary-eyed
wow
that's very unique
I remember that script very well
um
because I was at work you know I was
just I was about to break into tears and
I'm like I'm in an office I shouldn't
you know I shouldn't be crying in public
they're gonna ask me if something's
wrong at home like that's the script
it's just so good
um no I mean I have tons of respect for
that writer
and it was never made
not that I know off but I mean
sometimes it takes 10 years
um hopefully it gets made
how do you like to create characters
so when when you're when it's based on
real people
um the challenge is to understand who
they are
beyond the obvious
um meaning you know and you'll see this
with biopics it's such a
especially when they don't work right
it's I don't want to get the public
Persona because I can find that on
YouTube
um
um especially on you know if it's
indulgent and um
yeah mostly lazy you know self-conscious
so I'm not going to talk bad criticize
any biopics but it's like I already knew
that you know that's an actor playing
that guy
um
but I want to see what happens backstage
I want to see what happens when they're
alone I want to see who they were before
they were
uh well known or confident about
themselves
I want to see what they do when yeah
when the world is not watching so
um
with the Chicago script actually got a
chance to talk to the guy
who was based on
um
and that was a
that was a big that was a big challenge
in there because he was a he was a
revolutionary and I I think he still is
a revolutionary
so when he read my script
um
of course you don't you know you never
adapt reality exactly as it is you gotta
change it up a bit and you get adapted
for it to be a story because reality is
chaos stories have a structure right and
you got you gotta fudge the facts a
little bit not too much ideally
so he wanted it to be like a documentary
so he basically called me all sorts of
names we had a great relationship until
he read the script and he was like
no you didn't write it exactly as I told
you I'm like well that's not a story
um anyway that's neither here nor there
but what you're trying to understand the
person how they see the world their
contradictions
um you know
how how they are three-dimensional
people
when you're making up characters it's
not that difference in the sense that
you're trying to find in your own
database
um attitudes that resonate and that
would build a possible individual
um and some just filter in there when
you're writing you know as I said you
know when you write a a couple fighting
or or a daughter a mother and daughter
fight or father and son fight whatever
it's hard not to think of your own
experience
uh either intentionally or
unintentionally
um so
um
there are guiding questions you can use
always
um
I remember there was a there was like a
six question uh questionnaire that uh
Neil Landau gave me at UCLA again I had
great instructors at UCLA and people who
I I still talk to
um and it was basically the questions
were like What's
um
what's the trait that most
that you like least about yourself you
know it was like introspection questions
but then how to apply that to character
like what's your crutch what's your
strength what's
um so again when I when I teach
character uh on UCLA I mean they're
um I give them multiple techniques ask
all the possible questions observe
there's an exercise that make them do
where it's like eavesdrop people don't
be creepy but you know when you go to
the supermarket eavesdropping
conversations and see how people
um relate to one another
just
um in terms of dialogue right notice how
some people don't finish their sentences
notice how uh the euphemisms what they
avoid saying
notice what they actually say and what's
implied with their body language
observate I mean observation is always
the key to character and dialogue
walking down the Santa Monica strand
you'd pick up fantastic conversation and
you don't even have to eavesdrop you're
just there and people
um yeah they're not even you know
they're not even concealing what they're
just saying about I'd say anywhere in
L.A studies
the truth is if you're a curious person
you'll find characters anywhere it
doesn't have to be La it can be any town
um
just notice how people are very specific
you know about
how they present themselves
I always say this to to my students when
they have to pitch like remember that
you're not it's not just your words it's
how you present yourself
they've already started judging you when
the moment you came in
so you know choose how you're gonna
dress for that meeting how you're going
to present yourself
um
just because now that they're they're
paying attention
right
um the same thing with the characters is
that you know how do they dress do they
care about how they look do they care
about appearances do they not
how do they feel about aging you know do
they care if they're wrinkled or do they
not care at all
are they overcompensating
exactly aging do they have any physical
issues that affects their personality I
mean not per se what I'm saying is that
affects the personality
usually there's a connection
sure
yeah or are they always another thing is
someone that's always bragging about
themselves
that that's speaks volumes yeah
um well that's you know
it's always um that's why I like to have
characters intimate moments because
um it's very your persona and um your
actual self are very different how many
people are depressed and we don't know
it that's right I mean and now
thankfully we're talking about it in
public but even now I mean I'm trying to
be honest with you but there's a part of
me that this is my Persona I mean we
can't help it you know I'm doing the
same thing I mean I'm doing my best to
be myself but you know uh just even here
yeah
when you're in front of other humans
your behavior changes and you don't
behave the same way in front of your
family your loved ones you know your
friends your enemies
that's true the cops you're just someone
else
the Checker at the you you're happy hey
how was your day oh great hey oh
everything's we have so many masks you
know yeah so many masks
did you catch that game the other night
oh it was great yeah all right well you
take it easy if you go to the DMV you're
gonna try to be really friendly because
you know that those people hate being
they hate their jobs and I don't blame
them so you're like hey it's beautiful
whatever I don't know
how do you find out what a character
wants I guess
I guess it has to be something that I'm
interested in
um
sometimes character will come out of the
wand comes first
the quest comes first and then I mean
it's not always the same it's always
different but sometimes
um
you want to explore a certain Quest and
then you wonder who would be the most
interesting person to me in this quest
in this Mission so is it the most
um
adequate person or is it the most or
really a fish out of water you know so
um
I have a thing where
um I tend to have characters on a
spiritual or
um
yeah abstract quests
and it's it's really an issue I don't
make it easy on myself they don't want
material things
I've managed to figure this out over
time
um and I've I've
um had some problems with people like
what's their goal I don't get it it's
like she won't she's trying to become
this or he's trying to understand
um with Leary he's like he's trying to
find he promised Harvard the the future
of psychology a new method and that's
why he got hired
and he doesn't know what that is
so and his students hate him and if he
doesn't find that method he promised
them he's going to be out of a job
a widower without a job at 40 with two
kids and by 40 I mean 1960
40 year old not today being to 40 years
nothing it's nothing but in 1960 Don
Draper was 36. so if you were 40 you
were old
so he's you know he's trying to find
something and he doesn't know what it is
and I like those sorts of challenges
um
it does you know it does
um turn me into somewhat of an
intellectual writer I guess because I'm
pursuing ideas
um but that's okay I mean if I guess if
the day I want to write a script about
uh people pursuing money I can
it's always easier if what they want is
a loved one or money you know because
it's tangible
what if it's the idea that they think
money will
I mean what what if it's this elusive
care that that okay they get the money
but then it doesn't fix what they
thought it would fix oh but I think
that's inevitable that's the thing you
know it's the thing with the want and
the need right so they want money
but they need to change you know the way
they're approaching life in general I
don't know so it's this idea that before
the midpoint there's a want and after
the midpoint it's about the need and
movies are usual I mean there's a moral
element to movies Hollywood movies at
least which is
you know they were trying they were
trying to be the biggest
um investors in Wall Street and it's
actually about uh finding someone who
loves you
this is a class evening we've seen this
over and over and over again right
um he thought he was after the job and
he was actually after love
um
but it's easier if you say it's a movie
about people desperate for money
of course when you actually watch the
movie it's not about that you know
the want is usually not doesn't Define
what the movie's about
and the reason why this works it might
sound schematic but the reason why it
works is that that's how people actually
are we you know we there's a lot of
denial I feel like in everyday life and
we tell ourselves we want thing and we
don't really know what we want or we you
know what we need
first movies do that in 90 minutes or
two hours but in life you realize years
later that you know I was pursuing I
thought I wanted to make it big in
Hollywood I actually wanted to you know
I don't know heal my wounds from the
past
if it rings a bell it's because a lot of
people are going through that sure well
a lot of people that go into
entertainment sure there's interesting
things that drive them
um incredibly happy satisfied people
don't need to tell stories you don't
think so
um there was there's nothing dramatic
about it and I feel like no I'm not
saying we should be miserable Let Me
Clear clarify this I don't think we all
should be tortured and and sad I'm
saying that
um movies need a certain dramatic
element now element of conflict
no one wants to see a movie about two
people who are perfectly in love
all the time
that's true
um
I'm not you know I'm not trying to be
dogmatic what I'm saying is that we you
need events and this and then but you
know it can be and and has to be like
but however you know and so
um
I don't know I I personally feel like
the need to express yourself comes from
something that you need to understand
something that you're lacking something
that
you could say the same for someone who
writes a piece of code
they're creating something there's an
Artistry to that code
sure I've never written code so I can't
talk about that I mean I any anytime you
create something is because you feel
like something's missing right
that's what I'm saying like you're not
it doesn't come from a place of total
satisfaction
um I'm not saying there should be
something missing in your life and if
you've got any if whoever gets to a
point where they feel totally satisfied
man I'm sure that's awesome I'd love to
be there but I feel like the second you
you become enlightened and at peace with
the universe and everything
I don't know why I would sit down and
write a script you know I'd be just I'd
be basking in existence
you know not not to get too
philosophical and a bit
um
and again I don't mean that you have to
be a tortured Soul no
I'm sure the people that write
you know the classic come back home for
the high school reunion and you know and
it's all in a neat package and it turns
out everything works out okay you know
that that's not that's different than
somebody who writes about you know
scamming investors on Wall Street or
something I mean there's a different
different mindset there maybe I don't
know there's room for everyone look
um this is the thing the the audience
again I think the audience is smart so
if you if you have a movie or a story
where um
a family is totally at ease and they're
all happy together after probably 10
minutes or 15 the audience is gonna be
like something's gonna happen you know
something something's bad it's going to
happen and then half hour goes by and
they're like wait when's something gonna
happen and then you know an hour goes by
and they're perfectly happy eating
peanut butter sandwiches and you're like
what am I watching there's nothing
happening right so that's you know even
if you want to write a perfectly happy
Story the audience is expecting
something some conflict
um and and I don't I don't feel conflict
is something artificial that you insert
into the story life is full of conflict
you know like
out there it's just you're stuck in
traffic that's conflict yeah it's not
someone died but you're like oh my God I
can't get to I wait I can't wait to get
out of my car and I've been in traffic
for a half an hour and I got to use the
restroom and oh my God I'm gonna get
home and I haven't bought food for the
cats
that's conflict all the time
I think you've said that good writing
demands honesty and a large degree of
emotional involvement
yeah
I certainly believe it
um
I think it's the most difficult part of
the equation
um
there's certain Concepts like honesty or
Freedom you know that I know what it is
but I can't Define like what is honesty
um
I feel like you know when you're being
honest and that's why
intuition is such an important part of
it
you only you can know that you can and
you you got to be honest first of all
with yourself
uh and that's why I question the notion
of idea so much which is I had a great
idea
is it honest
[Music]
um
does it resonate does it tingle you know
no then let it go
I mean of course you know it's if you
can have a lot of ideas that's great we
all do but it's just is this the story I
want to tell is this
um what I want to talk about right now
and I'm talking strictly from if you
have a choice right I mean again if
you're if you're hired
you've got to find your honesty within
that material because it's first and
foremost a job right you're an artist
but you're getting paid to do something
so if you have a write-up you gotta
write a procedural
well find your honesty
um
and make it work without within that
frame but if you're writing your own
story
um
we're we're all constantly changing uh
right and we're not the same person we
were two or five years ago so what
you're going to be interested in now or
what resonates is not going to be the
same thing and that's the problem
sentence with rewrites which is you
wrote the script at a certain point in
your life and then maybe you have to
rewrite to rewrite it two years later
and you're in a different point in your
life so it's really hard because you
have to reconnect with that emotional
you know State and maybe you know maybe
you wrote that script when you were
getting a divorce and you were
heartbroken and it was so raw and so
real and now two years later you've
gotten over your divorce and you're
perfectly content by yourself and you're
like oh my God I gotta go through that
again
you know
and and it is part of the challenge I
mean you get through it through craft I
guess
you go to the memory bank of emotions
but um
because it's not like I mean it's not
like you have to be in a constant state
of emotional turmoil right actually
that's the worst thing to write
but you you must have gone through the
experience to know that it's real and
that you know what it feels like
um
so if I if you ask me to describe what
honesty is I don't really know but I
know what I'm being honest
and it it takes courage and it takes you
know and it's exhausting you got to tell
yourself
this is not truthful when I'm writing
it's good writing you know sure I'm a
good writer but this is not the story I
gotta tell
um or I can do better than this
or I gotta dig deeper
uh right now this morning I was working
I'm rewriting something
um
and I I wrote a pretty decent first
draft let's see
and I sent it to the right people the
people I trust and they gave me great
feedback great
um very very profound and they said you
gotta be careful because you did a good
job but this is a bit superficial
you gotta dig deeper
if you don't want this to be
um a bit lame
you gotta dig deeper and this is now
what the story is about like your story
is not what you what you're saying it's
about it's not really about that
so my honesty there is to say they're
absolutely right and I had a vague
feeling about it and they're telling me
that and I gotta listen to it
um so the challenging thing is so this
morning you know I didn't just sit down
and write I had to figure out okay how
do I dig deeper why do I want what do I
want to say and no one can tell me that
you got to figure out yourself right you
can ask friends but they're not gonna
have the answer because only you know
your materials so
you know I've been trying meditating
um and I'm new at it so I don't really
know how to do it but it's just like you
know closing your eyes taking deep
breaths and trying to go deeper within
and
see if something comes out of that like
what do I actually want to say through
this
uh and it's that process of you know
being patient with yourself but also
don't get don't get distracted you know
be patient but
don't do like 10 minutes and move on to
something else because it's very easy oh
I have to answer some emails you know
no no no no no don't get distracted take
the time figure it out
um
so I don't yeah it's it's I don't know
what the answer is I know that you you
get a first and foremost be honest with
yourself
and you went to people for feedback who
didn't
totally just gush over it they but then
they didn't rip you apart so they gave
you
this is great but I need you to go
deeper there's more to this this is just
skimming the surface their feedback uh
confirmed that they were the right
people to give it to and they identified
the problems that I suspected myself
without me having to say it
[Music]
um
and they gave me the right amount of
validation and said you know it's not
that uh far away you're not you know
it's closer than you think
but this is
one of the best feedback I got actually
was you're missing a part of the
equation
um so this this this guy and I wanted I
wanted to be the producer he said
um
well I don't know how to explain it
without I'm not a reveal the whole story
but it doesn't matter what I'm saying is
there's an object that produces an
emotion in someone right and she's
trying to understand why
she's reacting the way she is to the
object
and this guy said it's not about the
object you're making it about the object
and the answer is that there's something
happening in her life before the object
comes into it and she's not aware of it
she thinks our marriage is perfect she
thinks her professional life is perfect
and what the object does is reveal that
it's actually not as great as she
thought so
the object itself doesn't mean that much
yeah sure you can explore what it is but
it put you know it it causes if if her
life is like a pawn it's the stone that
causes the ripple effect
so I'm like mind blown yes yes good
point it's missing emotional impact
because I haven't done that part of work
so it's an object that reveals an
unraveling I was making it about the
object itself
and that's too cerebral you know it's
like no you can then figure out why the
object has that effect on her
but it's not about that it's about
herself and how little she actually
knows herself and how that the whole
thing unravels and she realizes wait a
second do I actually love my husband I
thought I did does he actually know me
do I know myself my job I thought it was
so stable and you know and this woman
who is this woman my mentor yeah
which is an interesting script to write
but I mean it's it's it's hard you know
it's not as easy as
yeah they want to win the tournament can
they make it can they get to the finals
you know that's another story
that's a progression here the
progression is not as clear I mean you
got to figure out okay
it starts off with the object it ends
with her discovering herself
I gotta fill out the wrist you know
what's the journey
um and there is no clear-cut answer I
mean only each person has their own way
to answer that
um
see but that's
talking about challenges that's a
challenge this script is driving me
crazy I mean
why did I put myself in this position
well I guess because I um
I don't know it's what I have to write
right now
and that's what you were talking about
maybe earlier is just getting lost in
the story and all great writers will go
through that maybe just because yeah
it's not going to be clear-cut
um well this is the thing um sometimes
you come up with an idea and um
I don't know how commercial what I'm
writing this thing is but this is one of
those scripts I'm writing for myself
um because it's almost the end of the
year and I can I mean I've you know
while I'm waiting for a contract to come
through I'm like I'm gonna write this
now
um if you want to be more commercial of
course you can't be that
um you know you got to be more
grounded I guess so you can find
references and I you know I always tell
my students um steal still not in terms
of content still in terms of structure
right find comps find movies that are
similar to yours and break down the
structure
not the not what we actually see I'm not
saying Steel character steel dialogue no
that's awful what I'm saying is
your movie similar to Wes Anderson's
style then go check out the Royal tenor
mountains and see okay scene one
character a says this thing to character
B scene two so the structure how does it
evolve and then you can fill out that
structure with your own ideas
and this is this is the history of art
right because you're not really stealing
because it will never resemble that work
because by stealing it it's becoming
yours
and I mean the whole history of
filmmaking and and storytelling works
that way right Shakespeare was stealing
from the Greeks it's fine because you're
not stealing the essence you're stealing
the structure
um
so I do that all the time I look for
comps I study the structure
um especially if they're great I'll see
what they do even the subplots I'm like
look they have this subplot interesting
was it necessary I don't know but it's
great it adds flavor to it
um yeah
what do I need what don't I need
what can I get rid of
what was the structure of Nightcrawler
um Nightcrawler for example it's it's a
very uh it doesn't innovate in terms of
structure it's um it's a very clear
progression
um it's about a guy living in the
margins of society
um he's not even a part of society and
he's there's something off about him so
it's how he takes advantage of a crooked
system to escalate in it until you know
exploiting
and the flaws in it it's interesting
because he has no Ark
so in terms of structure it's actually
it's if you if you check this it's very
easy to recognize the inciting incident
of you know the First Act break the
midpoint the low point it's it's it's
almost it's external almost it's obvious
because the movie's not about that the
movie is obviously about escalation
what's interesting is that this guy the
hero is an anti-hero and um
he doesn't have an arc
so usually it's desirable for characters
to have an arc to learn something so to
say to change to evolve
this guy since he is
um a sociopath
and it's it's really hard to identify
with him
but he's also a victim of the system he
doesn't change
and it's how he ends up winning
so it's a very pessimistic story it's a
movie about how this awful guy finds his
Niche and exploits it and his people
around him and
yeah makes a lot of money and doesn't
pay the price for it
um but the structure it's it's very easy
to copy or or borrow from because it's
just the beats keep escalating
what about the Rene Russo character does
she have an arc
uh she has a little bit more of an arc I
think
um it's a descending Arc you know in the
sense that she doesn't get any better
she actually succumbs to this guy's
ambition like never-ending ambition
uh she's a bit more human in that sense
um
it's it's a weird movie because it's it
kind it kind of feels like a movie with
a message and movies with a very strong
message
you know it's not very dramatic to have
a very strong message
you know like
um movies shouldn't be a vehicle for uh
ex
um
exposing an idea no no I mean again I
don't mean to say how things should be
it's just that you don't want to be
didactic you know you don't I I don't
like movies that tell me what how to
feel or think
um I like when we start to contradict me
or you know make me question my own
beliefs
and Nightcrawler in a in a weird way
gets away with that
I don't feel like they're lecturing me
but it's about like look how awful the
society is
right like
look how obsessed and addicted we are to
the news cycle that
even this guy producing news is well
received
um I don't know look I'm I might be
wrong about this because I'm thinking
about Network speaking of that back and
and back in the day 1976 I think and
network has a very strong message and I
love it so
I guess it's all a matter of how you do
it
we hear a lot of writers say that it's
impossible to pitch their story ideas to
Netflix
recently you pitched a show to Netflix
is that correct
um no I I didn't recently pitch a show
to Netflix
um I um I don't have the experience of
pitching to Netflix I pitch two other
um
networks or or streaming services
I've I've had meetings at Netflix and
they were very cordial I would say but
um
I'm curious what what do they say about
what makes it so impossible to pitch
well maybe that it's closed that you'd
have to have someone quote walk you in
because it's so sought after and that
would make sense that there's a barrier
to entry you know especially now because
you know
um yes so I mean
um before you could just pitch you know
with with a log line or a proposal or
something I think with Netflix now you
need to have for sure a script and maybe
two uh you know if it's a show maybe two
episodes written
uh yeah sure so Netflix doesn't need
that much content they you know they
have a lot of sources to get it from
uh or they even buy already produced
content and they they recently bought a
couple of movies that I was surprised
like you know Mexican movies like a cop
movie and um prayers for the stolen
which is the Mexico entry for the Oscars
and I was pleasantly surprised because I
thought wow those are actually
interesting choices I don't know who
they have in mind
a cop movie I I love Alfonso rip
Palacios the director but it's a very
odd choice for Netflix like who you know
who are they who's their target audience
but then again I don't know how much
they paid for it so maybe it's not a
significant investment
you said you did go to Netflix to at
least um yeah I remember a meeting I had
on Netflix
um and I was actually surprised this was
2019. I was surprised how aware they
were of
um International shows
um
This was
um before this this latest Trend where
you know the squid game is an
international phenomenon and some of
those Spanish shows like a money Heist
so
um there's been a big change in the last
two or three years in terms of
American audiences opening up to foreign
content you know and then parasite and
winning the Oscar and suddenly people
reading subtitles and I don't mean just
in La I mean not you know because of
course La is very Cosmopolitan but
um so when I met with them they were
seeing that was going to happen it was
the beginning of something and they were
very aware of shows in Argentina and
Brazil and South America
um which was interesting
um so that was the impression I got that
um
we were getting into and I think we're
right in the middle of that where it
doesn't matter where the content is
produced as long as it's good
and I think the squid game is I mean I'm
not talking about the quality of the
show which I think is pretty decent I'm
not a big fan but
um it's original and people don't care
if it's good they'll watch it
yeah so
how did you get your meeting at Netflix
um so I I
um I was involved in a fellowship called
tomorrow's filmmakers today
um where I met uh mostly for for Latino
filmmakers and I met a bunch of um other
colleagues that some you know that ended
up playing a really important role in my
life
um friends colleagues and that's how we
got a meeting at that time we got
meetings with different places with uh
HBO with Netflix
um with Disney
um and they really you know and it was
they received you with a ceremony and
everything like it was a big deal
um and you know it's good because I mean
even though it's it's it's not easy to
get anything picked up by them it's good
to know that they're there and
that you're part of that
um environment right and then the thing
about being in La is that it's all
happening there I mean you can just go
into the Hollywood offices and it's that
you know Netflix is around the corner
um
I haven't pitched them yet though but I
mean I'm open to it
so you were there as a group with with
other individuals who were all yeah we
all got a chance to talk to them I mean
so it wasn't a big group so the chance
to get to know them and and meet and um
yeah it was great
what did you bring with you
to the meeting
um well I didn't get a chance to show
them my script
um but I did talk about what I was
working on and my previous experience
and there's so much about it that's not
just what you write but who you are you
know and this cell people are just also
investing in you I feel like
um
your previous experience your background
your interests your passions
and if you're if they want to spend time
with you
so it's just a matter of introducing
yourself and telling this is what I
write this is what I do this is what I
like you know
this is my my plan
what does it mean to be bold I think you
said something where you you have to be
bold to make it in Hollywood what does
bold mean yeah I'm laughing because I
mean again make it in Holly it's the
expression that I I said it but it makes
me cringe you know because make it it's
like what is making it and the more time
I spend here the less I know what it
means it's like to get yeah to get paid
I guess to do something you love
um you gotta be bold in the sense that
you got to put yourself out there and
it's really hard and you know we all
struggle with it
which is
um
sometimes we feel like we're more
comfortable
in a place that's not really comfortable
which is
you know I'd rather not go to that event
or that screening or I'd rather stay
home and watch TV because it's so
hostile and all that and sometimes you
gotta show up
um you know you got to send those emails
and the thing with emails or you know or
texts if you have the phone number and
you have a relationship
sometimes they don't you don't get
replies you know you uh you get
rejections people ignore you they don't
get back to you you know
you think you're gonna meet and the
meeting gets canceled
so being bold is
um being persistent you know being
getting out of your comfort zone because
your comfort zone is not really
comfortable
you think it is I mean I'm I tell this
to myself every day
I think you know I'm a writer what do I
do what I know how to do is to write and
you know well no that's not it because
you can be an amazing writer and no one
will notice
um and it's hard you know learning to
put yourself out there is hard
and sometimes surround yourself with
friends who do it and learn from them
I've
you know I I hate it but I had to teach
myself you know go out to that event
meet people follow up
um
you know
friends that can get you into things
tell them can you get me into that event
you know and and you meet people of
course then you know
you gotta have something to show and all
that
um
be nice to everyone you know invite them
ask ask them out for a coffee or drinks
um at some point things will start
moving by themselves you know
uh the other thing I noticed with time
no one likes to read scripts so I've
been thinking of directing something
myself I'm actually writing something I
want to direct
because people don't like reading but
they're like watching
so
um even if you don't get into Sundance
or whatever
it's something to show you know and um I
think the best way to make something is
not thinking about the result but um
just doing it because you feel like you
have to
you know
um so
there's not one single way to do it this
is what I'm doing right now
and hopefully it pays off
and I know you said earlier that the
term making it makes you cringe and I I
get why that would be but
do you think the longer that you're here
or that we are here in this town or in
the industry that the term making it the
needle moves so it's like this spectrum
and and making it when you first got
here would be one thing but then after
you've been here a long time you realize
no
there's not really a making it because
it's then one project into the to the
next and that idea of success it just
keeps moving you know there's a carrot
that you can't grab
I think I think it's healthy
to demystify the the idea uh I think it
was Gertrude Stein they used to say
there's no there there you know in the
sense that
um one thing that has been helpful
living here is realizing that that I
aspire to is here I mean that
um you know I got a chance to meet in
Vegas uh Tom Cruise right oh nice
and it was just we were just two guys in
a room sure he's a mega star and
whatever and his you know everything
shines about him but you know the fact
that I can have access to that guy and
he and we can talk means that it's not a
different world you know
um it's funny when I back in my country
in Argentina and people ask me like so
what's Hollywood like I'll say well it's
mostly a bunch of people in offices
you know it's not glamorous sure I mean
you go to the Emmys or the Oscars or
whatever and they're glamorous but the
rest of the year
there's still a lot of people in offices
saying yes no yes no do we have the
money do we want to spend the money and
then going on shoots and you know
shooting anything is not glamorous at
all so it takes a long time you know
uh takes a lot of waiting
this is the thing no one talks about you
know like movies are glamorous no movies
are not glamorous events are glamorous
shooting a movie is strenuous it's
exhausting can be frustrating
[Music]
um that's why actors have trailers
because they have to wait you know you
gotta sit up
um and then when you're in development
you're meeting in office is having
coffee
and a lot of times it's just saying no
because it's
from their side the exact side it also
takes courage you know saying no is easy
you don't waste money saying yes well
that's where it actually starts
um I don't know I guess we're all here
because we think that it's possible
it's possible to do what we want and get
paid for it it's possible to um
make a career out of it
and when you're here the truth is I you
know I think about this often is I gotta
remind myself there are more things in
life than a career I mean of course I
gotta pay rent and that's a big concern
you know I gotta make a living ideally I
can have enough money to also buy other
things and
eventually sent my kids to college and
all that but um
you know we get so obsessed the whole
the whole struggle here the hustle you
get obsessed with
it's all about work and I'll work 24
hours a day if I have to in weekends
it's like no what's the point you know
especially if you do something creative
it's really hard to do something
creative if all you're doing is working
um you gotta find some balance
or try at least I mean if you have no
choice I get it but
um it can all be about work all the time
and making it
it's not sustainable
I see you know I see very young people
who are exhausted
um again because I want to talk about
the back side as well you know like
people who are actually doing really
well and are stressed out and are
exhausted and are not sleeping like
you gotta sleep you gotta eat you know
anyway
when you tell your friends in Argentina
that it's Hollywood is really a lot of
people in offices what's their reaction
[Music]
um
I guess some people ignore me because
they want to keep thinking whatever they
want to think people who are in the film
industry there which is it's barely an
industry it's way smaller I mean there's
a lot of production but
I think they find that um interesting
encouraging they're like oh really that
makes sense or they ask me do you go to
the beach or I say rarely I don't you
know I forget there's a beach yeah
you know I'm a writer I'm just uh
I think it's you know every time you
reveal something
um The Backs you know the backstage or
the back flip of uh something people
imagine it's always interesting
nothing you know nothing's as glamorous
or as exciting from the inside
um it's a good point
hopefully the writing itself is exciting
you know
the other thing I always say is a lot of
the times the people in charge the
people have the power don't know what
they want
um until they see it
you know so if you get rejected
um it doesn't mean your script is bad or
it does it's not worth it I mean
it's all very subjective
it's very easy to get discouraged when
you get turned down
in contests or fellowships and you're
like oh my God I'm awful I'm not good
enough
maybe you know maybe they they were just
looking for something else
I was a finalist for example I mean one
of NBC's writing programs I was a
finalist and I did really well in that
interview
um
and I didn't get it
and um
they told me it's you know don't take it
too hard themselves they said you know
it's like we had to pick I don't know
six seven people
uh so I didn't I said you know what
I could have been one of them I mean
it's just
it's also a matter of luck and you know
context
this project you want to that you're
writing to direct do you plan on
shooting it here in the states no I'm
actually it's interesting I I'm writing
that to shoot in Argentina for several
reasons because I'm I'm setting it down
there
um and also to be perfectly honest
because the exchange rate is really
beneficial
so
um if you have dollars right now
you can uh you can do whatever you want
in Argentina all right and you know
toddles go a long way again not to imply
that I'm going to exploit my fellow
countrymen
because I intend to pay really good
salaries but um
you know it makes a difference
the currency fluctuates a lot there yeah
inflation is a really big inflation
[Music]
um
but again I mean you can you can get a
an amazing
um crew and uh equipment and everything
and uh really qualified people and
actors and
um and it's also a great way for me to
reconnect with my own country I mean
it's not just a Financial Choice it's
just that I Really Wanna
reconnect with uh
yeah with the language and and the
culture and
the stories down there
how does a writer gain confidence in
their voice
I guess the best way to get gain
confidence in your own voice is to
practice
um
practice explore
make sure that it feels right
um
sometimes your voice and car
incorporates things from other writers
and that's okay because we all we're all
influenced you know like you'll say like
you know I want to be more of a
Hemingway sort of writer it doesn't mean
that you're going to be like Hemingway
it's just that there's a certain uh
musicality to it or
um I think with time and practice
eventually and by trying to enjoy the
process your voice comes out it's not
one of those things that you can force
you can't you can't fake it
because sooner or later I mean you'll
get exhausted
it just feels right it feels like
something you would say it feels like
this is how I express myself
there's a little bit of
self-consciousness in it but also you
want to surprise yourself
you don't want to just get stuck in one
idea of what your voice is
do you think it's easier to write in a
fictional name like a nam to plume just
because you can then express yourself
more without the worry of judgment
interesting I've never done it
um
maybe I should I I've thought about it I
I actually admire uh writers musicians
who um preserve their identity I know
um in some cases we know who they are
with Elena Ferrante for example the
Italian writer who now
has there's an HBO show and and Maggie
Gyllenhaal actually adapted another
novels I'm seeing her but we don't even
know if it's a woman
we don't even know if it's one person
several people if it's a man there are
many theories about that I think it's
fun
um but um it's very interesting how that
whoever did that whoever writes those
novels
it goes it's counterintuitive to our
idea of ego and recognition and success
right it's like wow you took the time to
write all that
brilliantly and you don't want any
credit for it because you have a fake
name
I don't know maybe that's the way to go
um
the same thing with with bands I
recently saw the residents who have been
playing together for 50 years and nobody
knows who they are they wear masks
um I should try it and maybe there's
something liberating
and then there was a Spanish female
author correct that we find out we found
out there were two male writers that
were sort of embodying this woman maybe
I'm getting the country wrong that rings
a bell I I don't know exactly I know
that at some point I think uh Woody
Allen who you can't quote anymore uh
jokingly said that Shakespeare was
actually Four Women
maybe I don't know I do know I will say
this on a more serious note there's
something to be said about collaboration
you know
um we haven't touched up on this but I
think about it often I love
collaboration it's really hard to find
someone to collaborate with
uh
again it's it's almost like a romantic
relationship you gotta understand one
another and share certain interests and
certain Dynamics that's why so often
it's um siblings who do it you know like
the Coen brothers or the Duplantis
brothers or
um
but uh there's something about
collaboration that's just so much fun
and there's immediate reassurance that
you're on to something
the only issue it has is that for the
industry they want to label you as a
team
um so it's they want to Market you that
way so it's really hard to collaborate
on one project and then break that
Society
what are the tools a beginning writer
has to learn
in order to write for film and
television
um I think that the first thing to do is
um watch a lot of films and TV
um read a lot of scripts
um
certain books can help but mostly I'd
say if you read a script start breaking
down Scripts
okay
um study the format study how they use
dialogue how they describe study
characters and how they're presented
it's very important to have to have
strong character presentations you know
the way you introduce them
how is it effective how do we know
that's the protagonist
reading scripts is the best way for sure
and and watching a lot you know and
maybe reading the script and then
watching how it was made
what gets lost you know
what they removed from the final version
of the story
reading a lot and writing I mean that's
really the only way to learn how to
write is to write and write and write
and write and write and get all the bad
scripts out of the way first we all have
those fat Scripts
um and after a while they get better
and by by studying other people's
writing and asking for feedback you get
better
you've mentioned that you love Paul
Thomas Anderson when you look at his
scripts and then you watch the films
what stands out to you
um PT Anderson is a freak of nature I
adore him I am
I love him deeply I recently saw his
last movie and I he was there to
introduce it um such a pleasure to hear
him talk he's so articulate and so
you know real
um I think both PT Anderson and
Tarantino who many people have um you
know they compare in many ways
first of all because they're both
originally from La which is a rarity in
itself it's weird
um they have an authority to speak about
the city because they were born here but
um
they're both amazing writers and this
doesn't get said enough I feel like
people talk about them as directors and
they're amazing directors some of my
favorite
but they're also incredible
screenwriters
Tarantino is an amazing screenwriter he
has a sense of timing and
he's become so much more sophisticated
with time
uh ptenders I think what I admire is um
there's an energy to what he does
um
it's not even a quality of the story
itself his characters have this sense of
urgency no matter that if you watch his
movies they're always like pulsating
take um There Will Be Blood Daniel Lee
Lewis or Adam Sandler and punch drunk
love or in Magnolia or in this last one
characters his characters almost run
they can't keep still they have to get
their they have an anxiety
and I feel like that's the most
distinctive thing
but also I mean he never makes the same
movie twice all his movies are so
different in genre and tone and
aesthetic and he shoots with different
cameras and
um textures and colors
he's just it's one of those guys who's
um he emanates you know Cinema
see I don't even try to imitate him he's
just in a whole different League
that's what I was wondering when your
students ask you you know I want to
become the next and then fill in the
blank
do you have advice for them where don't
actually try to emulate that style
I would never tell them what what to do
I my advice would probably be try to be
yourself I mean
um
or sure why not try to be the next BT
Anderson the odds are you're going to be
the next you
um
there's only one PT Anderson and we
should be grateful he exists but I mean
this I can say the same thing about Lady
Gaga you know what I'm saying is it's
great to have role models we all do but
at the end of the day you're not going
to be them
you're gonna be you
um
I don't try to make all the things I I
love you know I mean they're movies I
love and I could never write them
it's weird I mean
when it's when you get started and when
you uh probably go to film school or
something like that
um you maybe you confuse your taste with
what you produce
but sooner or later you realize that you
can love certain kind of movies that you
will never make or TV show you know I
can watch sitcoms I'll never I never
write sitcoms it's not natural to me but
I I'm happy to exist
I have a Maya Angelou quote here and it
is you can't use up creativity the more
you use the more you have
foreign
yeah another of those Concepts I I know
what it is but I know I can't describe
it I mean
I know that you can stimulate it
um you know it's it's
we don't necessarily control what what
um
what what stirs creativity I mean I know
that um
I do know that when I'm not feeling
creative certain influences will help me
get there
um when I watched the latest PT Anderson
movie in a theater I was exhilarating
I'm like I need to make go make
something now
um
the same thing some paintings can do
that you know sometimes going on a
museum can stimulate you going to
concerts or even listening to some music
alone and meeting certain friends you
know sharing experiences
anything can stimulate creativity
sometimes you know maybe even spiritual
religious practices going out for a hike
uh motion usually helps I feel like when
I'm too static you know or lazy
the odds are I won't feel creative but
you know maybe you work out maybe you
um take a long shower maybe you read and
maybe you I don't know go out for uh
getting out of the house
I I mean this for writers who usually
work from home or their office you know
getting a space to a different space to
work out you know change the location
so I agree with the quote